[Music]
foreign
i'm just jumping right in and they the
fans hate it when i do this i need to do
a full
intro um you know these two
from their recently oscar-nominated film
the female brain in which one of them
appeared
yes they were not invited to join
them i killed it though but why do can i
tell you something
you can that scene okay there's a scene
with you
and blake griffin it tested so high
that we almost moved it to later in the
movie because scenes after like couldn't
follow it wow
it would like kill and then the next
scenes would just bomb that wasn't our
first time working together blake
griffin and i we worked together on a
shoot for nba so we had some
oh chemistry it's comedic chemistry well
because it was already so funny because
it was like
when you're hanging out with someone
you're friends with but the role is that
you have to be like unctuous
like and like sweat them a little bit
it's like could be weird but it was like
so funny and we couldn't get through
because you were making blake
laugh so hard that it was like fucking
up the takes and as you guys may have
noticed i didn't have a ton of money or
time on that movie
um and so i was like can you guys
fucking stop being so funny because
uh we have he was making me laugh why is
he so funny it's annoying hilarious
he's he's one of the funniest people
i've ever met and like
he has great comedic timing too great
amazing
i'm not going to say that your
appearance in the female brain which by
the way i never knew how you guys
decided who was going to play
how did we do the part was it rock paper
scissors it might have been rock paper
scissors
okay and i and i won the one i was
delighted did you
i did i did but did you it was great i
feel like when they
when they nominated for an australian
mdb doing like the female brand
yeah i don't know we need to do like a
retroactive raspberry
right yeah i know i had a good time it
was so much fun
uh and obviously new brennan's like we
worked with neil before too so it was
just
it was just fun i had a good time it was
also really funny because
we you were a window washer right and
like
it's so uh we're writing like a rich guy
like i don't even think
now that we know rich people like that's
not even a real like having a win
that was to us like how do we sell that
he's like really rich
like someone's washing his windows at
6am it was so clear we had no idea
like what a rich person's life was like
no idea no idea they don't have just
they don't have
rich people i mean i don't have people
washing their windows i mean probably
not when they're inside
you know it was kind of like wouldn't
security have maybe gotten totally
it was just like but also we wanted to
show that he
uh is really kind to the people that
he's around even if they work for him so
they kind of
he was like oh sorry man like remember
he was like felt so bad
like as the thing was going down it was
like a little save the cat
type of thing but it's so surreal to
just be sitting with you guys
again because i sat in post for truly um
i don't know first thing i directed uh i
hope that's really obvious
um i mean we had we had to shoot
god we shot how long was the shoot i
think it was 14 days
um uh and we had to shoot the whole
thing i think in 14 days for a really
wildly low amount of money yeah
um uh and i'm trying oh yeah so the
shade kept coming down yeah we couldn't
fucking get it yeah so in post we had to
digitally
shade you at different times so i've
stared at you for
like days i hope it was a pleasant time
like i'm like hey
fuck you no it's like when you've spent
so much time with someone and they
haven't spent it with you right
right that must be airy now i'm here
yeah now i'm just like
it's weird to not see you with something
um but uh
so i don't even know how to i don't even
know how to describe what's going on
with that
i mean you just made the movie i the
fact that you just
came from the oscars what was what a day
ago it was a day ago a day ago
yeah and when i saw the first scene of
the movie i was like this is winning
everything
i mean you were robbed that's obvious
you know but let me tell you something
okay so daniel won though you know
as soon as you walked on screen it was
like it's done this is over just give it
to him now
but i had a theory about this because i
was like oh my god they didn't fucking
win i was so mad and i
i truly i believed it deserved it right
and i was like oh now maybe
like they're probably going out of their
way to like if they give this an oscar
they're admitting they've been racist
maybe they can't because like the most
thing you can do is go no you know when
i was like i was like in my head of all
the conspiracy theories of what
goes on in the oscars and um but i was
thinking about it like they're
you don't want to win an oscar this
young no 35 35
yeah no yeah yeah you think it would
have derailed that car i mean
like i'm just saying like too young like
tatum o'neill
right right right right roberto benini
right we still have something to strive
for
yeah or something you know i just like
comics like we
like we do well when things go well and
then something goes wrong like
i totally agree i think we operate best
when things are negative
like and i don't want to say losing
oscar is negative because people are
dying and that's
awful thing to say but i i feel like
it's funnier you know what i mean
it's like literally it is being a winner
it's just
it that's your your challenge moving
forward is like how do you
stay the underdog when you're the
winner right we're doing a cellar our
kid do not and now we're on stage we got
off and we're like okay something feels
a little different now
because of this oscar nomination right
and we knew like we gotta turn this
positive into a negative right that's
the only way we're going to
yeah i survive see this moment as like
the pinnacle of our career they have to
see it it's like oh this is something
we got slighted we were robbed like i
still want to be able to tell dick jones
shit i want to be perceived as the
underdog i mean that's
i think comedians work best from that
position right
that's really fascinating even though
like what was that moment like
when you're i mean first of all i've i
was
tripping out when i was watching you two
and little rel
this is literally like the hallway of a
comedy club in the oscars
right right yeah it was wild yeah it was
it felt
it felt like we were finally having a
moment as comedians and and
not that we haven't had like serious
moments but it's like now the oscars are
finally starting to
perhaps maybe embrace comedy in a in a
bigger way
ideally and i want to talk about that in
a second about how i think comedians are
the most qualified to write drama and
why
we'll get to later um because yeah
hollywood just wants to you have to be
one of the other and you know
um but uh but what was did you have a
speech prepared
no no i was like what no i didn't have
prepared
yes you did i did you would just go into
you're on drug
uh i was gonna let shaka do most of the
talking and just
sort of proceed to the background and
tell jokes
with my hands or something i don't know
what and whatever he said i was going to
say what he said
that was the only place i had already
did you have like a game like where you
like show me the right one you started
i mean we i had a sense that promising
anyone was gonna win i mean she
i mean you know it was a great script
and emery was winning everything so it's
like
it felt like we just weren't going to
win so i didn't i didn't it's white
women's turn
you get to the back of the line please
yeah i mean okay i mean yeah the history
of the academy black people don't win
we get nominated occasionally but yeah
we don't really win all the time
i did hear you um say somewhere that
this was the first uh uh academy award
when
for a civil right someone playing a
civil rights leader right yeah i think
so david
um did not get nominated he was yes and
he we talked about it when he was on the
podcast
and they very i mean i whatever he
should have been nominated
yeah but no he was nominated i think
didn't win
martin luther king didn't get a
nomination but the joker got two yeah
two wins for the joker i mean let's be
nice i mean let's be honest i'm going to
be playing the joker one day so let's
not burn let's not burn my bridge
with todd phillips right now oh the
joker is great if there was a female
joker would be me you don't need any
makeup
um but uh but because um they you know
they very much believe that it was
because they were
protesting that sure eric garner at the
premiere they all were the i can't
breathe shirts
and it was before oscar's so white so
you know it was a time where
i think the the institution was kind of
not against change but definitely like
you know i don't think they wanted to
like embrace like
active politics especially on like the
black side because
maybe they felt like it was too
confrontational to the largely white
audience
of the the academy is what i'm guessing
it's like they didn't want to like go
that far
to the to the left i mean
it kind of makes sense because the
ratings aren't
there's a reason only old white people
watch it
um but uh and here's the other thing
like if you got asked to host the oscars
which i'll do it
i would want to do it if only only if we
could do it with rel and jermaine fowler
together all right i would do it because
it's like their hat like when kevin hart
ended up not doing it after that
debacle i kind of was like two i mean
thank god
there's when someone solo does it for
like it could it could go either way
ruins your career or kind of turns you
into a talk show you know
i mean anne hathaway has not had been
the same since
it was rough she did that with james
franco yeah i mean it was
not a good show when did she get
nominated for a night was it before that
or after
she won for um something what did anne
hathaway
just get in marriage oh that's right um
when she
and then she hosted with james franco
and i remember writing on that
i think stoller was running the writers
room on it and i was a writer on it and
um
she's like a broadway girl so we were
writing her like she was in like duck
costumes and she was a ballerina and all
this stuff
like franco like i don't really know and
then sure enough it turned into like
she's like carrying the show
and like you know i think comedians know
to do this broadway people know
to do this that um i have a speech
impediment and everyone's finding out
about it
that's why i didn't want to start a
podcast and now it's oh you sound great
i used to practice an hour for a year
and then you heard me say it after i
rehearsed it
yeah i just mean before you do an hour
you can kind of get away with stutters
on stage
sure for sure you know but uh in a
podcast you really can
it's like are you on drugs no this is
just my personality and my fucking the
way i talk
right um but uh but then we know that
if someone gives you less energy you're
just going to give more
so that's why i didn't like improv it
was like i hate it i mean improv was
like
it was just too much it was like i just
you just and i was not very good
you're a real writer right and i
remember being at those improv things
and they're like zip zaps up and they're
like
yelled the audience like they have any
fucking idea what is funny
they're like we're just coming here i
thought you're supposed to know what's
funny like what should we make jokes
about and they're like what i thought
this was your job
i do i see the benefit of it like when
you're doing crowd work
why it's good to have an improvisational
mind so you can react to the audience
because you can get some really good
moments from the audience right
but you don't want that to be the hour
like right that's strange that's special
for the live
audience that's there they get to go oh
my god i just saw a show that no one
else saw
right right improv i remember being in
like
improv classes or something and then
you're doing the improv and you're like
what if we stopped and went and wrote
something
down and then said like i always wanted
to go write it and make it good
yeah i was always like this refine it
right like take take a very funny
you can get a lot of funny ideas from
improv a lot take those ideas and
sharpen them up yeah and make them make
them tight i think that that's sort of
the process that most stand-ups go
through
we will generate ideas either just by
observing
or we'll play around on stage but then
we when we find it we go and we sharpen
it up i've always wanted to ask you
this in your special on drugs which i
want to talk about in a second also but
when who walked around who and that what
they did but didn't didn't one of you
walk around the other one and you're
like sorry i just walked around you i
think it was you you
tend to walk around him and you know he
was like it's all good it was just such
a funny
like just sort of like specific way to
start and i just remember being like i
just love that like i didn't know it was
planned or not but i remember being like
um being so like endeared by that yeah
we were trying to like capture like how
our normal sets go
so it's like normally we're just like we
we try to figure things out on stage
they've been blocking before so
there's a wire the wire and the mic
around and get into like comfortable
spots so i think we were just trying to
capture that yeah it just felt like
abnormally comfortable right right
everyone's first thing it's like what is
that they're good
and it's like super forced and intense
and it just felt like oh
i just i didn't the beginning of most
people's specials you're kind of like
okay just getting your act oh my god
don't panic because it's
the first time we're doing stand up
right right right in front of 19 cameras
and like there's no way to be natural
and
i found a way to do it and i remember
being like fuck i was like jealous
like yeah apologize for some weird shit
at the beginning that no one expects
that's clearly not part of the act
like i just was like ah right so if you
had to give a speech yeah what who would
you have thanked
i think i would have thanked the academy
for i think i would thank god for it
thank god first
yup thank god for saying even though i
don't necessarily believe in god
yeah why would you thank them if you
don't well i have a different i have a
conception of god that i believe in
what is that what is it let's just hear
you have like a different conception of
god right not the christian
you know god it's more like uh you know
uh
caa
you know we're like uh you know the
scientific version of god
the einstein yeah more einstein version
of god a bit more abstract and for those
that you don't know
they were philosophy age right studied
philosophy
so i am uh in a 12-step program so we
say higher power
right yeah right and it's basically the
only thing you have to really
acknowledge especially in the beginning
if you have shit with religion and
catholic school and being a white guy in
the sky and all this stuff
um is in order to believe in god you
just have to believe that you're not god
right we just need to take your ego out
of it as long as you don't think you're
god we're good
i was watching the the crown and it was
a scene with
uh prince philip speaking of old white
guys
i figured it was a great story but no
it's relevant because it was prince
philip and his
mom and uh she asked him about his like
how is he doing spiritually
and she was like you know whatever and
she was like you got to believe in
something
anything i don't she was like a devout
christian but she like believe in
something and she's
just the best way to go about it i was
like yeah that's right i think
because i just think there's this thing
where uh uh i'm just so excited about
this answer um from y'all because a lot
of
comics i think especially and people in
general like i don't believe god i don't
believe god fuck religion religion
stupid like
it's like well everyone's got their own
whether it's crossfit
whether it's your instagram whether like
you're something we're all trying to
just
find meaning and a purpose and like you
might get it from someone else but i
think when people
slam religion it just feels very elitist
it's like a bunch of like rich hollywood
people like fuck religion it's like well
you don't need to look forward to
something because you
or you don't need to build community you
have people that work in your house
or whatever yeah i mean you know we grew
up pretty poor and i i saw the
the positive ramifications of having a
religion in an environment where
you don't have anything right you know
it keeps a community together right
it gives people hope when there's
nothing to be hopeful for
so like i see the the pragmatic value
of believing in uh religion and
christianity but you also recognize like
the
the negative ramifications organized
religion
but it's not just organized religion
it's extremism right it's any sort of
belief system that's
you know believed in an extreme way that
you know leads to violence i think
religion has that
tendency sometimes but it could also
just be a crazed fan
or a person or government or government
or
even people who are anti-religion they
they can be zealots as well so
uh i i feel like you got to be able to
look at both sides right and and see the
good and the bad and i see a lot of good
in religion but
with that said i i just don't think i'm
comfortable with accepting it
philosophically yeah yeah that's
the the rules part like that i mean
we're comics our whole thing is like
break the rules do the opposite of what
we're allowed to do um you know but i
i do like as i get older i get
some of the rules like because i'm
always the fuck these rules but then a
friend of mine
her mom died suddenly orthodox jewish
and there's a plan in place like when my
dad passed it was just like i wasn't
eating i didn't know i was in the
hospital i didn't know what the fuck to
do or where to go like
like orthodox they bring food over they
have a plan
for 30 days you do this and then you do
this and this person shows up it was
like all planned out
so that you're not like great so i was
like oh okay some of this is just like a
positive investment in your shoes
yourself
right yeah you know but um when kevin
died like
i didn't i had no plan like it was just
like it was booze it was like
just sadness but you know our jewish
friends they
had a plan and i was like kind of
observing going through it with them and
it made it so much
it made it better yeah like just being
able to spend time with them spend time
with their family and just like
recognize how serious it is but also
find like the beauty in death you know
what i mean like
don't look at it so negatively but like
it brings people together in
a weird way and it's like it just taught
me not to
be so hard on myself during the grieving
process as i
go through it in the future because i
know i'm going to uh but it was very
hard in the beginning like i was like
how am i going to get through this how
because at that time i was away from my
religion
yeah grief is a wild one i don't i've
processed it in like little waves
and then it'll come up like do you feel
like you
like repressed it and you're like i'll
save this for later yeah the first year
i wanted to go into it it's
hardcore like i was like you know what
i'm to fully embrace the emotions that
come with grief like i'm not going to
shy away from it
the ugly the good the bad i didn't care
i was like i'm going to do it
i'm going to do it the honest way and i
feel like in the beginning it was very
hard like couldn't sleep
yeah and sleepy but you have to feel
everything you know like normally when
people would die
in my family i would just like spread it
off and just go right on
move right on with my life right but i
found that that was just like
not the most appropriate way of handling
that yeah
when kevin died i was like i'm going i'm
going to film all the emotions i'm just
going to
fill all of them but that one is like
god like
when it's you're an older person your
dad you're like okay well this is going
to happen
this happens but when it's someone's so
yeah young it's like it's just
and kind and you know um
it's just it it it makes me a nihilist
and yes
uh it makes me like being an existential
crisis of what the fuck's the point of
without a doubt
sure you start questioning everything
yeah you start questioning everything i
mean
you know we studied philosophy so so
naturally we're we've already started
questioning everything
right when someone who's your age in
your profession who's in your
you know class you know dies it makes
you
even more philosophical even more
existent but i actually think like the
philosophy that we had the training that
we had in the
early on sort of prepared me for that
aspect of grief like
i understood it philosophically so i
didn't go to a period where i was just
like
fucked like existentially like in
trouble it was more the psychological
impact that i wasn't prepared for
the overwhelming amount of like sadness
and emptiness and like
feeling like it's like unfair and like
the having to see his parents go through
it like that shit
i wasn't prepared for at all like i
don't know i don't know where you come
from i mean you've talked openly about
where you come from and seeing a lot of
death and chaos
you know but this was like oh no i was
used to that this is this is that
became like okay that's just what it is
like it's just i expected that i became
numb to that or something because she
was like wait a second this is my friend
we lived in we're in l.a like this is
what's happening
he was on a trip to you know like a
fancy trip crazy making a great show
like it just was like this isn't if this
is so sudden yeah
what the fuck did you at all study on
terror management theory when you guys
were in philosophy i don't know
it's it's basically um and i've heard
y'all talk about versions of this anyway
um uh but the book
that i read on it was called the worm at
the core but essentially it's about how
we're since we're the only species that
knows we're gonna die
right we have to essentially um create
indelible things
and uh in order to have some sense of
immortality
that's why we want prizes and awards and
trophies and teams like we need to align
with something and
family crests and shit like that and how
we get preoccupied i was just asking
myself this question like why are we so
obsessed with
like metal things or like having our
name engraved somewhere
like and i i never thought it's because
of our fear of death oh yeah we want to
be immortal we want to be immortal
something
to so um i'm trying to google it right
now but of course
i can't uh because i'm a woman and we're
just inferior
um so no you're right we want all the
oscars right there
um
did you know there's a google called
google scholar and it only came up when
you two were here
it's the only time i've ever seen it
like the lucas brothers are there we
need
her to step it up you gotta go scholarly
i know like get off your fucking
uh internet explorer wait that's i've
never seen that before
that was like i think that was like
having google like earth like earthquake
on the show and having it just go to
google earth
you've never used google scholar i've
used it once i feel like i've used
google scholar
yeah yeah yeah i don't know when it's a
good one it went to like a lexus nexus
or something yeah you definitely use
less
lexus nexus
oh so this isn't really philosophy i
guess it's psychology it's both social
and evolutionary
psychology theory originally proposed by
who cares white guy
and codified in their book the worm at
the core the role of death in life it
proposes a basic
uh psychological conflict results from
having a self-preservation instinct
while realizing that death is inevitable
and to some extent unpredictable this
conflict produces terror
which is managed through a combination
of escapism and cultural beliefs that
act to counter
our biological reality with more
significant and enduring forms of
meaning and value
collections you know why do we collect
stamps
why do we put our name on things why do
we need to like
be a part of a team like the cowboys
versus the i was going to say redskins
and i did it
but i said it anyway i'm trying to not
say yeah you know giants
[Laughter]
um we can't offend giants right no no
they're not a group
as long as
i'm sure there's ways that a comedian
can make that
wrong but um but yeah there is that
right i think and then when i lose
someone it's more like i've gotta
shoot a thing i've gotta like get my
name and a thing
you know like it's just such a wild it
feels like narcissism but i think it's
self-preservation right i think it is
self-preservation
i mean i think it's like it's that fear
of you know not being known or
i don't know dying without people you
know but whatever
what i've learned through history is
that the people who are like normally
remembered
like for a long time or either like
religious martyrs or
uh uh emperors who
kill millions of people like like a
caesar or
like you gotta do like crazy things to
humanity to be really romantic really
famous
yeah yeah yeah remember like yeah hitler
was like i like the jews i just like how
you're famous
that's right like i just keep my name in
the street i'm just saying gotta do it
you gotta do what you gotta do i don't
like eating women
um but let me because this is going i
really i want to get to the movie
obviously i have so many questions and
um
i was my first question is like in
making and telling the story
which is like the fact that it took this
long you know it's shocking
i know why you did it scripted and i'm
glad you did but was there ever a point
where you're like oh do i do a doc
do we do a documentary about this do we
do scripted like
well i mean i felt like there was
already a pretty good documentary yeah
the murder of fred hampton and i'm like
i don't want to
tread the same material i felt like it i
felt like his story
uh needed a sort of cinematic
representation that
really liked to connect emotionally to
connect like this is a human being it's
not a bunch of black and white pictures
getting zoomed in and out on yeah so
i mean i felt like that was the right
path uh i think ultimately it was proven
correct but i feel like
uh you could have i mean i think there's
still a good documentary waiting
i mean there was a great documentary
about the black panthers recent for pbs
but there might be an even more specific
documentary about what happened
post hampton's death related to like the
you know the the legal case that they
had well between the family and the city
of chicago
and i think there's a lot of material
there that you can explore in
documentary form
i felt like the story that we were
trying to tell especially william
o'neill's
yeah worked for cinema right and then
did you get to meet his he has a
doesn't isn't his widow alive and yeah
yeah she was uh we've met her several
times we actually
we were at the uh the oscar after party
for kaluya and she was there
but also with chairman frederick that's
your first time meeting her no no no i
met her we met her on set
right uh we met her uh when we rapped
we met her i mean we also uh talked to
her um
what else are we those those are the
only three yeah yeah
and did she like offer any information
oh yeah
yeah yeah she was crucial to she was a
consultant oh nice
so she was on set several times and she
offered advice throughout the whole
process and she's
she worked uh specifically with uh
dominique fischbach to you know make
sure
her you know her character was
authentically uh
portrayed so she was mama cool is very
crucial to the to the development of the
story and my
like big question is like just we were
just talking about history and stuff
like
i have this theory that a lot of history
is like just fucking gossip
like i know i know they say history is
written by the winner
but it's like as you were researching
this digging into it i mean obviously
this was later when you know we had
um we're able to like write stuff print
stuff file stuff like you know
um i'm working on something about
harper's ferry which is where
um john brown and there's all this
um you know a free slave built this
hotel called the hilltop house there's
all this stuff and there's just like
rooms and rooms of files that are
of this the plans and wb dubois came and
gave a speech and it's sort of like none
of this is in history books like it's
just kind of like sitting here
and like half the stuff i learned in
history books like if you'd asked me
10 years ago i'd be like yeah
christopher columbus discovered america
and him and the native americans they
had a thanksgiving dinner
where like the pilgrims were other cute
little boots and they just like
in some reason they disappeared i
remember that i guess they were just
like you know
so i'm just so curious when you were you
know because there's such an absence i
think of
of black history that is told at all
like where did you work from in terms of
your
yeah i mean i i think that you have to
sort of immediately reject
everything you were taught in school
like you have to just question the
motives of why they presented it that
way and why they decided to keep out
stuff and
i think once we got to college we
started to develop more sophisticated
tools of research
yeah and i felt like in college they're
giving you a more honest or a fuller
representation of what the history is
somewhat slightly there were no slave
revolts like
no i just don't think they were around
to tell the story right
and it wasn't even in college it was you
know there were still some limitations
to you know how we were educated i think
it's important to do your own research
to read as many books as possible uh
just to get a again a better
understanding of what this history is
about
and i think that you know obviously
college was helpful but then we read
this book called the assassination of
fred hampton which
gave even more uh context and uh facts
and details to what went down
and the fact that it was called
assassination and not murder yeah right
that's important it's important because
i i mean it's like you know there's
stuff where like the fact that i didn't
know this
you know like you know i knew about this
a couple years but it was like the fact
that we weren't taught this in schools
is nothing short of criminal
he since the fbi conspired to kill him i
mean killed him
yeah but it makes sense why they would
want to hide it like it makes sense why
they would want to repress it and
i mean it's basic soviet union tactics
where you're just like
let's just pretend like this never
happened yeah yeah you know america's
great and we don't assassinate our own
citizens for
talking is there ever like are the
people that were in the fbi at the time
are any of them alive
i doubt it yeah probably not during that
time and
probably a lot of them are probably dead
really but you know like younger
like is there no one around that could
like
maybe go like all right i was a part of
that like or do you sign something
that's like i could never talk about it
again
or they just they kill you they could i
mean they could
i mean i'm sure that they participated
in like
extra judicial assassinations of people
who might have spoken out right
i mean i know the cia definitely did i
mean why wouldn't they
because then were there no people of
color working at the fbi during that
time there were people
there were people calling there might
have been they might have been moles too
oh gosh yeah it's grimy yeah it's so
it it literally it makes it does feel
like russia when you're like oh you just
poisoned someone if they fucking have
the crazy thing is it was like
apparently it was like 7 500
like black informants across the country
so it wasn't like this is just one story
of many
you know a black of the fbi using black
informants to
to spy on you know other poor black
people not even just poor but black
people in general
um scary it's it's just it's it's like
you know
it's tricky because um sorry to do so
many dorky philosophy references i do
them with people and they don't know me
we love it it's like um i'm obsessed
with um beau gerard who is
like the simulacrum am i pronouncing
around simulacra right yeah
right so it's like essentially like like
um
how uh jean beaujolais wrote uh the book
america is really amazing about how
america everything became like a
you know a simulation of something else
like las vegas is a simulation of the
pyramids in egypt the simulation
but essentially when you're only exposed
to the um or like candy like runts
like you eat runts or or grape gum and
then you have an actual grape you're
like oh this is gross
so when you've had the simulation first
you actually prefer it to the real thing
you know and there's just sort of
something um you know just
in the space when you hear the real
thing you're like oh that's a movie
right yeah and then you're like no no
that really happened oh yeah it's
strange
isn't it weird because you're yeah
you're presented with a version of
america that's simulated it's like it's
a it's a fiction and so when you
when you uncover material that
contravenes that
fiction you're like oh this makes a good
movie but it's like oh no this is but
it's true
that's what i'm saying because when you
guys say this is like oh that sounds
like a great like michael crichton
plot yeah you know like weird and then
when something
you know so it's like um i was just uh
you know um back touring and
i went up to idaho and was like driving
through and looking at like these
beautiful trees and i was like meh
like my screensaver version i like my
screensaver version is right here
it's like when someone's like joining
this concert i'm like but i can just
listen like i can watch a youtube video
why would i go
you know so do you think the pandemic's
going to change
how people you know interact with the
external world
because we've been so locked up maybe
like now we're going to be a little bit
more
you know appreciative of like going to
concerts being around people
i can say when we were at the oscars and
we were around people and we were
watching it like
it was a little stuffy but i was like no
this is actually it felt good to see
people
out doing stuff yeah i mean well i mean
it's probably to see
ava and meryl streep it's probably a
little more fun
than the people here around it's
probably not there but it was definitely
like i feel like it was the more
the most relaxed version of what that
ceremony
used to be right like i feel like i
would have been way more like
nervous if it were doing like the
traditional way but now since you know
we were adjusting to the pandemic i
think people were just a little bit more
relaxed
i think like you know i think there's
like a lot of answers i think to that
question i think it depends on the level
of fear you have i think
isolation for a lot of people is way
worse for their health than
getting it you know like i you know um
uh
you know especially comics like i you
know a lot of people in our
lives are you know mentally not you know
necessarily as balanced and and doing
stand-up is what the glue that kept us
a lot you know the coping mechanism that
made us feel seen and heard and
you know i know that the first time i
went on stage and did stand up like did
terribly but i was like
this is the first time i've ever felt
yeah mm-hmm like okay
like okay like when people talk about
like their drug of choice
in meetings uh a meetings or n a
meetings they go like oh i did that for
the first time and i felt normal for the
first time yeah and that's sort of like
that's exactly how i feel was saying
stand up yeah it was the only like i was
going through a lot of crazy stuff
at my at the time in my life just like i
was like dropping out of law school
breaking up with my girlfriend and my
girlfriend
but yeah i was going through a lot of
crazy stuff and and then i
stepped on stage and it was the only
time where i was just like oh this feels
normal yeah like i i feel like i have a
mic and i'm just
it i mean maybe you're kind of crazy for
sure i don't know but it felt right
i mean i don't know other people go out
and do like bachelorette parties till
two and then
like i'm like i don't know what that
that to me you know like i think a lot
of
like we just happen to have this very
specific coping mechanism and i think
when
a lot of rough shit has happened to you
going on stage and
being able to joke about it is like just
like a modicum of like oh that didn't
happen for nothing
right right that's what happens to me
it's like if something bad happens and
and you can sublimate it into either
helping
other people heal or laugh or get make
money out of it even if it's fifteen
dollars
like all of a sudden that wasn't just
god hates me right
it's taking ownership over to trauma
right you know i mean sometimes
i know in the past i would let the
trauma sort of define me but
as a stand-up comedian you can sort of
just like take that trauma and like you
said turn it into something that's
humorous get paid off of it or whatever
like a case in point like
our stepfather was abusive growing up
and uh i hated to do
and for so long we didn't even want to
like touch that material like we didn't
want to touch it because it was so
overwhelming but then we started telling
jokes about it and it felt
it felt so good like it felt like we
we're winning like yeah
i don't know i don't hate to do anything
yeah
cause all of a sudden you don't own you
i don't have to keep a secret
yep you don't have power over me anymore
because if i'm keeping a secret about
you you still own real estate in my
brain
and there's something so liberating
about being like this happen and then
when people laugh you're like
oh yes other people have gone through
this
it wasn't just me it was like whatever
and i can go okay i forgive alcoholism
her people hurt people that person must
have been abused precisely precisely i
can like get out of it because comedians
we play devil's advocate
so i get to go like okay the person
abused me but someone abused him too
and i have to now which is why going to
law school is like
i think makes the best comedians because
i always say we're like shitty lawyers
we take like
we take like a shitty premise and then
we try to prove it with jokes
you know something that's not true at
all and then we convince you it's true
yeah we don't care about the truth like
no no
our intention is to do it the joke right
we want laughter yes
but we use a similar well lawyers don't
care about the truth about the truth
[Music]
try to we try to take a lie and make it
true with jokes right
in like a fantasy language like let's go
on this mental exercise but like yeah i
do
i do feel like as soon as you talk about
something like that
it is sort of like okay well now i don't
have it doesn't have to keep me up at
night it's not it's yours too
it's just given to the world like when
we wrote that that piece for vulture it
was like it was one of the first times
where i felt like we were being
brutally honest about our upbringing
right and once we wrote it and released
it to the world it's like oh that's such
a burden lift it right i don't have to
think about this stuff anymore it's
already given to the world right and no
one
um likes you less right you're not gross
because a lot of us like i'm holding
this in because it's like i don't want
to
be seen i don't want anyone feel sorry
for me i don't want anything i'm a
victim
like i don't want to be like you know
and so uh i think there's something
about that where everyone's like oh
okay i didn't lose anything i just
gained more space in my
heart and in my it's liberating it's
like liberating like yeah you definitely
don't want to be seen at the victim
but you certainly don't want to keep
that that shit in you know yeah there's
something about like okay that's and now
it's finally in the past
right yeah right finally yeah so i have
a younger lover as you all know i know
you hate the word lover but hate it
until i get a better what am i i'm 30
years old when i'm saying my boyfriend
no nip me my
um uh adopted son
so these young men they're fearless they
are
fearless he will straight up say you
have a mustache
and i was like no i don't he took a
photo do i have a mustache
that's baby peach fuzz i know but i
think in certain lighting no that is
those are pubes those are pure ones if
those were pubes people would keep pubes
well you haven't seen my poops they're
like i know you don't we hear all the
time
you don't you're a barbie doll here's
the thing they're here's they're
starting to grow back a little bit and i
don't trust
any razor on my crevice i
am now using billy razors not only for
my legs and ankles which have started
getting incredibly hairy
as i get older uh yeah it's the worst
when you go to get like a pedicure and
you just see a giant
like rogue hair coming out of your ankle
and you're like
since when never happened to me okay but
i also love billy raisers but i started
using billy razors i don't know if i'm
allowed to say this on my mustache have
not gotten a negative comment from uh
the boy in a minute and oh you know what
else hold on let me actually
all right here's the best endorsement
for this goodbye sir i can do it no no
today because i'm going i'm between
houses right now
uh and i didn't have a billy razor this
morning look
i shaved tried to shave my armpits
really quickly but for the interview
look at that look at that didn't use a
billy razor look at that now it looks
like my armpit has herpes
it might do you see it can i it looks
gigantic
this is this is all we need to hear is
that this is what happens when you don't
i i
used a non-billy razor for the first
time in eight months and you look what
happened
yeah this has like a thing on top that
makes it you literally can't cut
yourself with this
the fact that i have not shed one drop
of blood
from this i was wondering where that was
going to go yeah no because normally
let's just be honest when you shave
your crevices you got to pull the skin
you got to move
this you can just kind of do it yeah
eyes closed
dry no cuts razor burn can look like
herpes
and that can always be this doesn't do
razor burn and you don't have you know
how you normally have to like pick up
your leg and like right right
and push and like right pain you see
like pull have someone pull a straight
disc
you have to like fold the way they do in
gap stores you know what i mean
and this is like i'm just i'm obsessed
with this also
because look how easy it is to pop off
boop
no stuck i'm not i'm not an idiot i'm
not all of a sudden
an invalid can you help me with this
like i know how to do it
meet billy the best razor out there for
those who wait you can't say that now
shave it is here's the other thing we
talk about the pink tax a lot on the
show which is the fact that like
a product that is the same for men and
women right for a man cost 50
cents for 40 of them and then two of
them for a woman is
12 yep well not with billy not with
billy no pink cats no pink decks
and to express a little love for our
show go to mybilly.com
whitney it's a small way you can support
us while getting the best razor you will
ever own
it's just nine dollars can i say
something and i get started oh
good girl girl she knows what to stop
talking
we had a fan uh angelica angelica said i
got native deodorant and i got a
billy racer just to support your show
and then i got it and it changed my life
and now i ordered all the time
ringing endorsements yeah it was like
she literally was like i'm obsessed with
it i
like i just bought it for you and then i
was like these are such organic
cells i yeah i don't lie yeah no i'm
sorry i'm not full of shit emily oh i
am i'm real oh that's right that's right
okay i'm sorry it's just nine dollars to
get your starter kit plus free shipping
always go to mybilly.com
whitney spelled b-i-l-l-i-e dot com
slash whitney
ernest i am very interested in talking
about you because
student loans were a big part of my life
until i started working i paid them all
off at once because i was so
i couldn't handle having but then i went
back into debt paying
like the first okay like time i had 80
000 i just paid them off right away and
then i broke again because i was like
i didn't like it hanging over my head
right and i don't like the loans
they get more expensive the interest
interest even if you were like a math
major or an economics major
you're still doing bad math later like
college should have taught us
the first thing they should teach you in
college is never go to college get a
loan
yeah from a college oh no you know
so i am now with a man who
is a uh they don't tell you when they
say date a doctor they don't tell you
wait till he's over 45.
that's they'd only make money past then
they're in the
red you know yeah until they're in their
40s so he's a specialized
veterinarian right and he has loans
and it's when he explains me there were
he has sixty thousand dollars in loans
and i'm like that's insane and he was
like oh most of my co-workers have like
400 000
in loans and all they're doing all day
is saving dogs lives the fact that this
has not existed before is so frustrating
earnest is a website let's get to what
the product is
um you get radically flexible payments
you can pick your loan term you
refinance
your loan uh we've been working with
this company for a while so i do know
some of this they combine
federal loans with student loans i'm not
totally sure what that even means i
would need to go back to college
to learn what that means right but you
offers a low rate student
loan refinancing and you can check your
rate here's the you can check your rate
without it screwing with your credit
score earnest is offering our listeners
a hundred dollar
cash bonus refinance your student debt
at earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply now
ernest is giving our listeners a hundred
dollar bonus refinance your student
loans at earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply once
again
you get your hundred dollar cash bonus
when you visit earnest.com
whitney to refinance your student loan
not available in all states terms and
condition apply
visit earnest.com whitney for more
details terms and conditions apply
earn a student loan refinancing made by
earnest operations llc
and mls number one two zero four nine
one seven california financing law
license number six zero five four
seven eight eight three oh three second
street suite 401
n san francisco california 94107 visit
earnest.com licenses for a full list of
licenses
y'all are pretty open about um you know
the
circumstances you grew up in and the
environment in newark
um and i was just thinking and i don't
mean to be like the silver lining bitch
because i know that's annoying
i know it's annoying no you got to be
positive but i'm just wondering like
just in terms of the way that that
environment is very much about breaking
rules
laws don't you know we're doing what
we're doing and you know may have to go
to jail but it's a lot about breaking
rules and so is comedy in a way
like do you think any way like seeing
chaos and seeing rules be broken so much
at all influenced like your creativity
without a doubt like yeah without i i
would say without question there's
something about like
growing up in an environment that is
sort of uh
you know that has i don't want to say a
propensity but where we're breaking
rules is sort of like
not that but it's like it's sort of a
part of survival like
if you don't break these rules you're
going to either be very poor or you're
going to
subject yourself to like violence so you
got to like protect yourself the laws
are set up to
keep me great so we got to break them in
order together if the laws aren't like
devised to protect you then you have to
devise your own sort of platform to
protect yourself against like uh
you know very bad laws right because you
look at it from like you look at jews in
the black messiah the people who
were supposed to implement the laws were
breaking the laws
right and that's generally the setup in
most inner cities where
you know you you want to believe that
the cops are there to
to enforce the laws justly but
that generally that's generally not how
it's implemented so like you said you
have to
you know take it into your own hands
which usually leads to people
violating all the laws right because
they don't trust them and i think that
see being in that environment definitely
like made me question whether or not i
wanted to be a lawyer for the next 30
years
whether or not i could conceivably like
live a straight life
because at that time i was starting to
smoke and drink a lot more and i was
like
you know can i can i be a lawyer and not
be an addict and an alcoholic and
be a professional i was like i don't
think i can like i think i'm gonna slide
i think i'm gonna get disbarred but at
least you
understand where your clients are coming
from i don't get why you did all that
hair
i get it but we gotta get you out of
this mess
did i mean i know this is like a silly
question
but with everything that's sort of going
on right now and which has
always been going on i i that annoys me
people like with everything that's going
on right now and the
you know black lives matter movement and
cops killing people like it's been
happening
for a while we took a nine minute
murder for us to um shotgun in a
pandemic where
you know everyone had some some free
time for him some free time and yeah and
wanted to like get more likes on
instagram
um but it's sort of surreal
i mean i guess that the timing for this
is always kind of perfect but it almost
is like
i mean wildly emote to me emotional just
how the
timing is with this yeah it's it's wow
that the
you know the film came out i mean even
when we were developing the film
in 2013 you know that was right around
the time
after trayvon martin got murdered so
there's always been that context
we've been developing this since 2013
2012 2012 2013
yeah yeah yep wow yeah it's been a
long journey with this yeah that's wild
yeah like you were probably
writing on a show you didn't like when
you were working on your oscar winning
movie
i mean yeah we were working uh we were
working on lucas
knee deep in comedy while we were
developing the idea so it was like it
was a fun little exercise to like
you know work in that space and work in
this other space it's been it's been a
long journey it was so cool to watch
that movie after knowing your stand up
and seeing
and and the main takeaway when i'm
watching your stand-ups
um stand-ups that is the oldest thing
i've ever done
and that was that was stuttering
when you were smoking at the ganja
before your stand-ups your skin
[Laughter]
and uh and there's you're at the pacing
is like we're not in a rush like the the
and you and i've learned so much from
you because i'm like
and i think i was like okay i'm a girl i
have to work twice as hard and get uh to
get half as far and i have to make like
everyone laugh twice as much like i
can't take my time i don't deserve to be
here i can't claim my space or else i'll
get heckled or
sure people just start walking out i
mean that's just it's a different ball
game
for for for females in comedy for sure
i mean who know like you know i think i
got a lot of things i didn't deserve
really early because they needed to
check a box
for a lineup you know yeah i definitely
was seen for
a lot of festivals before i was ready
just because they're like we have to put
it well you can say the same thing
though i mean if you're
a novelty act you you tend to get a bit
more exposure as a comedian early on and
it's just it's just the nature of the
business they're trying to figure out
like who can be that next
big thing and i don't know i wouldn't
say that
it's undeserved though it's just like
you right place right time and right you
know
a lot of it is luck for most good thing
i bombed those
uh showcases so i didn't get anything
they took me twice as long
later which was good it slowed me down
you know um
but uh yeah the timing is so
unpredictable you know you'll sometimes
like your your setup will
kill and then you'll wait a sec and then
the and then you'll have like an
exchange and then the punchline will get
like it's
but every joke feels so different to me
like you're on a different little
journey and there's so it's so
surprising with the timing
and watching the movie you know and
there's i mean there's a scene where
they're all in the car and they're just
like laughing and it went on
and i was like oh i think most people
would have cut out
already because this you know everything
has to be so choppy and quick
but it was just like breathing and you
had to like take in their humanity yeah
you had to take in
them like laughing yeah and it i think
most executives would be like okay we
can cut that scene in half or whatever
i think that's what's so great about
like shaka and his directing like he
does a lot of long
takes so that you can't edit around it
you gotta sit there and like
feel that these are human beings that
are like laughing and
it was just like the chemistry was
unbelievable but i was like oh my god
this feels like
their stand up where it's like they'll
be short punchy scenes and it'll be long
scenes you have to just like take in
and the timing is just completely on
their terms the length and the cutting
of the scene is gonna serve
the joke or the scene not like the whole
movie is going to be the same way
yeah yeah all of the writers involved on
the on it like us
will burst and shaka we're all we all
come from comedy
right we often come from a comedy
background so i think that that's why
you know you could feel some of i don't
know comedic timing sort of
implemented within that script as well
because of the fact that we we've all
sort of cut our
cut our teeth in in comedy it's so weird
to me that people are like oh but this
person does comedy how could they do
drama yeah
and i'm like always i'm like it's
literally comedians jobs
forget the laughing it's our job to
surprise people
and in drama that's also the number one
sort of thing and like you just can't
like be corn also comedians just can't
be corny
you know and there's this like
constitutional need to make everything
um less corny and more true so like
comedians are the most qualified to do
drama
without an experience yeah i think it's
like our our goal is to evoke emotions
like i think we do it well in laughter
with punch lines but i think the same
thing applies to drama where you're
trying to evoke a sort of a
pathos an emotion from it and it's like
you treat that button of your scene like
a punchline right
i mean you want to get something out of
it before you go to your next scene i
think we're
fully capable of writing drama i mean
and also like we're
we're masters i mean you were nominated
for an oscar i think yes
but it doesn't matter if you think that
everyone else i think all comedians i i
i would take it a step further and i
think
especially the really good comics i
think that there should be a sort of uh
a meld of what we're doing in a dramatic
space and i would love for the academy
to sort of
uh recognize comedians for what we've
done for
the history of cinema and it feels like
there's still like a sort of a
bias against comics yeah there is for
sure yeah for sure and i think there's
but there's still
and i think you two are changing like i
mean hugely changing this but i also
think there's something with
comedians where when comedians are cast
in comedies they have to
play this sort of like arch version of
them like everyone has to be ace ventura
or something
now you know like it's sort of like that
worked really well when it did but i
think comedians like
like have to be like okay now we're
being silly and drunk
i just started like not doing parts like
that because i just was like i just
yeah i that it it's time i know why you
think that's my personality but i just
am like you
we outgrow that shit the special that
you're
offering me this role based on that you
wrote for me like i'm not that person
exactly like i shed that skin yeah
now i like schedule crying twice a day
and i work in therapy and like
i like make it a goal i did um 30 days
no trying to make um strangers laugh
or people like laugh it didn't last long
but it makes you realize how at least
how quick
i go to like yeah trying to make this
person laugh
it's like i'm in the starbucks line like
what are you doing like how low is your
self-esteem that you think the only
value you can provide to people
yeah or they're not even they're on
their phone they're laughing at memes
they're fine
you know it's just sort of this like
permanent always-on clown mentality yeah
and i wonder how much of that was
exaggerated because of
covet and not having the stage and not
being able to get that sort of
emotional need out on stage and now
you're just like you know you're just
going around just trying to make people
out i mean i don't know what you were
like
prior to covet maybe you were the same
on stage as you were off stage but for
me i felt like
because i didn't have the stage i felt
myself having more of an inclination to
want to make people laugh
oh yeah and just connect yeah anyway i'm
texting i'm telling i'm texting jokes
i'm tweeting jokes i'm just i'm just
like putting out jokes as much as
possible did you lose any friends to the
pandemic just of like what
just like not like either their
their behavior or their beliefs or their
the way they reacted
or the way that they coped like i had to
mute a couple people
yeah these ig lives are making me lose
respect for you but
i'll see you in a couple months yeah
block a friend he was
just like you know losing it i guess but
he's a good he's a good friend but it's
just you know this this pandemic has
been tough
tough on a lot of people so it's like
it's been um
you know i don't there is something to
be said for the like obviously the loss
of life is like horrendous but i always
got to go
like big picture silver lining silver
lining it's like i mean do you think
that the george floyd moment would have
hit his heart if they're
if everyone wasn't locked in their homes
or if everyone wasn't i don't think so i
don't think so i don't think so
i i just don't think yeah people were
less distracted
and uh they had time to sort of like pay
attention to police brutality and that
that clip was so brutal that it just
forced people
to to yeah everyone was just commenting
on it like it was everything was
happening in real time i think if
people had the luxury of not being
forced you know in their apartment they
would have just been like oh another
black guy yeah let's talk about the
trump typo instead
it would have just been another because
it's not like police brutality wasn't
happening before the president wasn't
way
i think people were just you know they
were just out and about
and they had so much to do and they just
didn't worry about it but
with with the pandemic again it just
forced people to like really really pay
attention
and so i think it had to happen for
people to react the way they did
when are y'all gonna direct why aren't
you directing it very soon
we're we're working on it comedians
directing is
the best because part of your job as a
director is to just stop the tension
like just cut the tension you know what
i mean and just make everyone laugh and
be in their play state
like i just feel like comedians are
specifically the
like so good at directing right yeah our
goal was like before getting into the
industry
was to transition into directing like
we've always wanted to direct but we
wanted to learn
you know space and you know how to lead
a production by writing and
doing acting but yeah the long-term goal
was directing right and the main thing
for every director is like i just was
there were two of me
someone in post some of the products i
mean it's cheating yeah right frankly
but um and then are you do you have a
movie in mind that you're
i want to draw we have a couple of
scripts that we've been developing uh
the one that we're eyeing i mean i don't
want to like practice oh you don't have
to
yeah yeah but we're iron untitled
whitney coming
yeah yeah about how hard her life has
been um
you know white woman yeah i get lost
sometimes in here
um but i uh i'm kind of fascinated by
your uh the last special when you talked
about you know the drug use and the
fermentation the micro dosing and stuff
uh the over this pandemic is the first
time i have ever done it
nice uh really anything i micro dosed uh
ketamine
um and then mushrooms a little bit and
then when my dad passed i did ayahuasca
how was that i've been i've been
thinking about that you've never you've
never done eyewash stuff no no you micro
dosed it so here no i did a
full sitting for two days of ayahuasca
up in topanga canyon right here
oh really and um i was just in so much
pain when my dad died and i couldn't
even organize it
like i was also had like rage
i was just like in re i would pour my
coffee and spill me
fucked like i was like throwing things
yourself as a situation just life
i was just like i just had so much pent
up rage and for me
you know sadness is always right or
anger is always sadness underneath right
i was just like i was just mad at
everything and like everything
you know um uh you know i know
um you all have a estranged relationship
with your father a complicated
relationship with your father
not being around and my um i had a
similar thing with my father and i think
you know i just um i was so angry
that i was like was i too hard on him
like i couldn't tell what was my fault
like when you lose someone
you're like oh i should have fucking
texted him back that day like you i
started beating myself up
i um i just i just wanted out
you know i just wanted out of the pain
and i think that comedians like we can
pretty much anesthetize anything or
sublimate anything
we can hang out with a bunch of comics
and be like this fucking happen to me
and you know it was the only thing i
couldn't
like get out of um pain wise and uh it
was also just really sudden and like
gross
where was your relationship with your
father at that point it was not it was
never
very it was not great it was it was bad
money had sort of ruined
it and um uh because when i first
started making money i started just
trying to pay off all my family's debts
and get
health insurance and all that kind of
stuff so i was like you know um
the point is i couldn't figure out any i
could only spend time with
animals like i was i went to this wolf
sanctuary and i was just like watching
wolf behavior because
they have such a plan for when the alpha
dies the alpha starts training the next
alpha like they're so in tune with
the fact that they're you know um they
they prepare
for that so i was just being around
animals was helping me um
and then i did ayahuasca and the first
night
i i was very like eye-rolly about it i
was very like okay
like a bunch of people in like juicy
sweatpants like doing iowa like is this
the new like soul cycle like
i just so many people were doing it you
know what i think is comics where like
if everybody's doing something we're
like
yeah and um and everyone's like it was
so amazing i'm like the fuck out of here
like your life was fine before
you know what i mean it's like a bunch
of trust fund kids being like i really
healed a lot of what
um you know having to pay like taxes on
your inheritance like what are your
problems like
so i i couldn't really understand it and
uh and then i think his comics like it's
our
our brain is to just find holes in
anything that's happening
so for me natural skeptics yeah there's
this guy and he's in a like a speedo and
he's got like
like you know and i'm just like white
dudes man you can make money
doing anything literally
questioning the legitimacy of this he
was in like beads and like lighting
can't i'm like i'm paying you two
thousand dollars like with what resume
just it is crazy at what they can do to
make money right right
oh by the way i'm it's like a power of
suggestion i'm going like
yeah this i don't want to make the man
mad like i have to make the man like
whenever i don't do massages because
whenever i do massage i feel like i'm
performing for the person
that feels amazing you like fixed my
whole back like i nee
i'm just trying to take it there take
care of their feelings and that's what i
felt like with ayahuasca i was like
fuck i have to cry or something so i
don't hurt his
white man's feelings because i'm wired
to try to you know
make you not kill me and um and
it was like he was in my face and like
singing and i was trying so hard not to
laugh i was just like
bro like this is too much he was singing
and dancing and like doing all this shit
i was just like dude this is
if a woman did that it would be fucking
like a like a set piece in a movie about
a crazy woman i'm in my head like
writing jokes
and um and i def i puked the first night
i just went and puked
and felt nothing and i was like this is
a total scam this is all power of
suggestion
this is like not real this is like all
placebo which placebo effect is an
effect it's fine if it works for you
great right
and then the next night i did a little
more and then i don't know if i'm alone
if this is legal but i went and smoked a
little weed because i was so bored i was
so
bored i was in an all-day thing like you
take it and your body is just going to
take five hours
and the good thing is i did get to get a
notebook and i was like writing like a
like are you
looking for a script you know so i was
like okay if i can at least write i'll
be okay but i was like sitting on this
fucking pillow i was so bored
i just like wanted i was like can i play
fruit ninja please like i was so bored
and then i smoked some weed and came
back in
and i did have it wasn't like some
transformative like tie-dye like i'm in
the sky i think it was
i whole i i didn't hallucinate i
realized that
during life all the time i hallucinate
so there was just these a couple
realizations that came over me that was
like oh that
family member that hates me that i gave
money to that i can't understand why
they hate me
because i tried to help them oh my god
of course they hate me when someone
when you don't have something and
someone gives it to you all of a sudden
they're just a reminder
of the fact that you needed that like i
was like i just saw myself through other
people's perspective like
comics that i didn't think liked me i
was like oh my god of course they didn't
like me i was a fucking billboard being
like
you know like i would have fucking
clowned on me too everything was just
like
all of a sudden there was like this wave
of like forgiveness and
um you narcissist every no one is
wasting time not liking you right yeah
you don't like you yeah and you're
putting that on other people
yeah it's like we spent all this time
obsessing over what people think of us
and you realize like they're just not
thinking about you right they're not
thinking about currently
thinking about themselves of course they
are because that's what people do yeah
that's what you do
it was just like a thing of like oh so
it was like a couple like super clear
crisp realizations and then i did um
like talk to my dad or hear him like
talk to me in a way that was like i
basically was just like
i feel like i integrated into my dad's
not dead he's still
like here and but like the best parts of
him are in me
right you know which is true yeah
because it used to be anything that uh
characteristics i had of my dad i was
like i never want to be like him i never
really i was like i was like that with
my my my my mom i was like i don't have
any characteristics like my mom but then
i'm like
why it makes me seems like she's and
what if i use her skill set or this
inherited ancestral like pain it's in
making it a like good thing right yeah
you know instead of being super
i think it's like you're just trying to
like you're just you're you're ashamed
of yourself
and you're blaming everyone else rather
than like honing in on why you're
ashamed of yourself
i think that was a realization that i
had like i can't i got to stop blaming
everyone else for my problems like you
know what i mean like it's it's my fault
if it just doesn't work if it worked i'd
keep doing it it's just like doesn't
it's like a temporary
just as you get older and you know you
start getting more responsibility and
you're just like wait a second like i'm
a 35 year old man i mean
whatever problems i have i have yeah
which is so
liberating in a way because if it's
everyone else's fault you can't fix it
right
if it's my fault like that's great news
yeah i can i
have control over that yep you know you
can take an ownership taking ownership
of the tragedy and the trauma or
whatever issues you think you have and
yeah i think you liberate yourself once
you once you do take that ownership
and i think there was something that i
came out of which was like like just
this radical forgiveness of like
okay my dad's dad was in a war
never said it like where would our moms
have gotten the skill set
to they didn't have tony robbins or
whatever they didn't have oprah they
didn't have like they didn't have any of
these tools like
why do we have such high expectations
their ability to
because of their sacrifices like your
parents make sacrifices for you to live
a certain way and sometimes it's hard
for you
to recognize why they had to make those
sacrifices is like you don't
contextualize it you're just like
you're supposed to do this for me and
that's that yeah and then as you're
getting older sometimes you have to deal
with some of their decisions but it's
like
you have to contextualize why they made
those decisions you know what i mean
and you also have to recognize that your
parents aren't perfect like they're
humans
like if we had kids right this second
yeah i think they'd have some notes
for us too like dad why were you on the
side of your oscar winning movies all
day you know what i mean like
yeah just because like
you know when y'all are parents and
you're shooting in new zealand eight
months of the year
and our parents weren't around because
they were doing uh untoward things like
the child doesn't really you know you're
still gone you know what i mean
so it's like you might be gone for more
uh socially rewarded
reasons but if you still absence is
absent our kids will probably think we
weren't fucking around sure
sure what are we gonna say to that like
they're wrong no
because we use the same justifications
to criticize our parents
and is it true that your um production
was the first all-black production yeah
yeah
yeah we had three um well chocolate king
charles king and ryan coogler you know
they were our primary producers and it's
the first time
that you know an all-black you know a
black production team was nominated for
best picture yeah it's incredible 93
years
crazy well that was also like
but for 50 of that black people weren't
able to
couldn't yeah it's sort of like as soon
i mean i used to have this joke that's
probably
i i we'll see uh how this goes about how
like like part of the reason people are
so afraid
of you know black talent is because when
black talent comes in it's so it's just
like
tennis it was over like as soon as and
then even country music hootie from
hoodie the blowfish
number one on the chart it just sort of
was like something around like that
right and um
uh but yeah there's that you can't
really go back once that is yeah i think
there is a fear
i mean it's definitely a fair i mean
hollywood is an industry like any other
industry so it's like there's a certain
a finite number of spots
available to talent and you want to
allocate it based on i mean i think the
argument is you allocate it based
on your proportion to the population but
that's not been true
for almost a century for black talent
where we were sort of relegated to the
margins
from acting to directing to writing like
we just weren't getting anything
so now finally it's happening where
we're getting more rolls and now you
still see there's a backlash to that
it's like we're giving them too much you
know what i mean
i mean but is that i it's like is you
know
those little backlashes like i think
it's important to
highlight i'm also trying to go like
okay on twitter
i try to remember that 20 what is it
um uh 22 of people are on twitter and of
that
80 i'm sorry 2 generate 80
of the comments of course you know yeah
it's crazy that's been the main the main
to answer your pandemic question was
like i was like okay everyone doesn't
want comedy anymore they want
lectures and they want to be told how to
vote and then i went out and i was like
no no no
we know that you don't believe that we
know we're coming to see a clown yeah
be a clown right we know that nothing
you say is true
you can say something offensive and it
doesn't offend us we know we're in a
comedy club yeah they don't care at all
like
you got to separate what's happening on
the streets and then real in real life
versus
what's happening on twitter right that's
a small percentage of people making most
of the noise
and i think what's happening is like
corporations comedians
and even people hollywood they're we're
being so reactive to these guys because
they can go viral right
and there's a fear that if it goes viral
would be bad for business i'm like
you guys have to learn how to weather
these storms because you can't let two
percent of the fucking country
dominate yeah what what the nerds that
probably are illegally downloading the
shit anyway and not paying for it it's
crazy
it's like we got to stop we got to stop
being so reactive yeah like these are a
small percentage of people let's go to
the people
who aren't on twitter yeah wasting their
and also
can i ask you about just saying that
moving forward it just makes me go oh my
god now all the pressure
is on you guys to like make movies about
all these like
figures like and then when david yellow
was on and and and ron funches
you know last week it was like can we
just do dumb black stories that don't
have to do with race and civil rights
and slavery
you know like how do you balance that of
like so many stories need to be told
yeah but also i think we're in the
perfect position where we can
go serious and talk about fred hampton
but then write a whimsical
animation show about smoking weed and
you know
going to hell to get your soul back to
fight in a soulful eating contest like i
think because
we have that range to just do different
things i feel like now the climate is a
little different like we're biting in
office and trump out
i feel like there's going to be and with
the covet with us coming out of covet
i think there's going to be a sort of a
want of happier stories
because you know we've already in real
life things were already so tragic
so it's like let's let's let's let's get
some escapism let's get let's get in a
position where we can
you know actually learn and grow
together with people and laugh together
i think that's what's going to be the
appetite and also it's like
you know there's so many different kinds
of stories we can tell from
the black experience that aren't you
know uh
premised in trauma and tragedy so it's
like
being able to like swing to the other
side just telling jokes i feel like
something that we're going to have to do
coming out of the pandemic because it's
i i do see this pressure
this unfair pressure from you know
people of color who are now
getting some power and they're like i
have to tell all the people of color
stories that are the
that no one else will tell and they're
sort of like oh now you
can't just you know i think especially
like if you want uh
to if you want like recognition from the
academy and like to be
taken seriously as like a filmmaker you
tend to like gravitate toward
sad tragic stories because it's like
that's what's gonna you know garner that
attention but i feel like hopefully
we can you know eventually move past
that
and we can tell just human stories that
are complex and
not necessarily rooted in trauma have
y'all um why do i keep saying y'all i
mean whatever i'm fully
off the grid someone i was with someone
the other day who said off the
reservation
um but uh and you know when you're not
supposed to say something you're kind of
like
don't say it don't say it and let me
stand to see what happens in front of
your mind
um but have you been on clubhouse at all
i used to go i went a few times yeah
it's too hard uh i don't know i just
i felt like if you're not like pret
there's definitely a lot of interesting
conversations going on and i listened to
some interesting ones but
i wasn't really participating so i just
felt like what am i what am i doing here
so i was just sort of in the pandemic
being like okay dumb
white woman that is like you know
participates in institutional racism
even when i'm not trying to
whatever all the time ever you know
everything you buy everything you do
every
person you cast everything um and
there was i was doing these clubhouse
rooms to try
to figure out why it's so hard to find
crew of color and well you know because
i was like oh i guess there's just most
of the
um uh uh line producers are white they
hire their friends that they
have delivered for them so many times
and then i was because they're so
you know most productions i've gone on
uh saved the last couple years the ones
that i had power on right i said no we
need to have like
um because i would uh have like my
friends of color be on the show and
they'd be like there's no one here to do
my hair
i was like what do you mean they can't
do black hair like what like just dumb
dumb
and i was uh talking to a bunch of i was
doing a room that was just about like
um uh hair artists nail artists makeup
artists of color and i was like what's
going on like why can't i find you why
don't i know about you and they were
explaining
that there's all these issues with the
unions where they have to have 60 hours
of union work but now most tv shows
aren't even that many hours because now
they're like six eight episodes
24 episodes the way they used to be so
there's all this like institutional
problems like within the unions
because i'm like where why are am i
seeing the same resumes over and over
again or why
is this so hard like did you um sort of
learn anything or come across anything
as you were making this movie and hiring
that you're like oh this is like an
institutional problem that is part of a
roadblock for access
yeah yeah i mean i i would say
just the entire academy experience and
competing for oscars and like
uh just how you know certain uh
um certain uh
magazines and journalists how they
perceive black films like it's just
a harder way to get recognized by the
academy like it's always like they know
they're going to be a certain
select slots for black films and they
they have to compete amongst one another
and then you'll get one and then even
then it's an uphill battle
like it's just all this like sort of
like institutional weight against black
films it's like we're not being
we're not being evaluated like the other
films it's like no we're a separate
category
and i i i didn't i knew it existed
before uh making judas and going through
this process but now going through the
process i see it it's like
you have white critics you have white
journalists you have white reviewers you
have
uh prognosis white prognosticators you
know you don't have people who's a
prognosticator people who predict what
what movies are going to get nominated
do you think that those predictions end
up
manifesting yeah oh yeah yeah so a movie
comes out
you know and people start to say oh okay
this movie is the front runner this
movie is
the movie to beat and uh that that
you know that comes true it becomes true
it becomes the dominant narrative and
you have to sort of fight against that
uh and so we came out late there are a
bunch of narratives already written
about what's the film to beat
and even if we like we made a great film
but i feel like
you know we were we were coming from
behind for the most part and it's like
if you're a black film it's tough to
come from behind and you know
because you're already like the other
ones are already in someone's psyche
they've already heard about it they've
already talked about it there's like and
then you have an
investment in because most people don't
like to be wrong
right then the ego comes in and they're
like oh i've already put my money on
this horse now i'd have to admit that i
was
wrong you know like it's just like oh
that's i've never thought about that
it's so it's just strategy and
campaigning but even like
in with this one like there were five
really really great black film
maybe even seven really great black
films that came out that probably could
have been that one black film right
that got the best picture slot so um
it's weird when you're like oh these
films all have uh
uh they're they're good enough and great
enough to
to to get the nomination but because of
all these
institutional barriers there's only
going to be one and it was just weird to
sort of like
accept that reality it doesn't matter
how great your film is
like you're still going up against these
uh institutional forces
again if if you had won you would have
lost that's my theory now yeah
it's just like it was like i don't know
yeah i don't like i i don't know i don't
know
i think it's like it's like two steps
forward like three steps
kind of backwards it's like yeah it's
good to be nominated but
the way in which it happened and to know
to know that these other films
didn't even have a chance like it just
feels weird
it's a with all the respect i mean it's
a it's hollywood prom i mean it's
it's it is like you know the way it
started was like to sell dresses and to
get more people to watch movie in the
in the movie theater owners would or you
know they would pay for the oscar to get
you know it was like
you know a marketing thing for the
longest time and now it's like
our your heart is on the line for it and
it's like oh god human emotions are now
involved you guys this is not just
yeah i mean the thing about for me it
was always like pragmatic it was like oh
it's good for the film
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's good for our
careers like i wasn't i'm not like
yeah i'm not i was never obsessed with
winning yeah i'm not obsessed with
winning an oscar with that
more people to see it and as a stand up
you're like okay what's
what's the best credit to come out to
you know what i mean you're just you're
just thinking about that
if you guys you will win an oscar yes
and i will still
be like you've seen him on craig
killborn
their premium blends uh they had a show
on c
so like comedians will never fucking do
that right
they will always no i'm not going to say
that no it will always
be shitty stand
shit always but um another clubhouse
room we were talking about and i know
we've talked about this a bit but
um a friend of mine um like my best
friend from college oddly is uh
uh uh john legend's partner in their
film company
and we got them where is it mike jackson
mike jackson
i love my colleagues he's older than me
to be clear
we met at a bar when i was in college in
philly
and he was like the promoter and we
became like best friends
that's crazy isn't that weird he's
amazing and then he was like i'm gonna
come out and be producer and i'm like oh
here we go
and then uh and then he's like i'm going
to dinner with these people and i'm like
cool
like i'm meanwhile just you know and
sure enough
i mean yeah he's now he's mike jackson
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm seeing him in houston next week
yeah but um yeah he's known me since i'm
18 years old
wow yeah wow yeah we just like run
around together in philly and like cause
trouble yeah
he knows more about me than i care about
you pimp right what's that yeah
i went to penn and philly and then yeah
and i would just like stay at his place
all the time yeah because i didn't want
to hang out with the
nerds um but uh so we were
we're always talking about stuff to do
together and you know we were doing a
clubhouse room just asking
you know uh uh people of color like what
do you want to see
let you know and it was a lot of like
you know because i went to see 12 years
of slave at the arclight and there were
no black people there which i mean like
and i was like where oh
right got it you know and
the overwhelming response is like we
don't want to see
trauma porn that's not for us like you
know seeing a
a a movie about a white cop you know
killing a young black girl like that
white cop is gonna
whoever plays that is gonna win a
fucking oscar for playing the nice car
like the nice cop that felt bad like
stop humanizing them it was just like
such a
you know um sobering i think moment
i can't i can see why black audiences
are fed up with uh
the trauma i mean they've been it's been
it's a lot to roots like that's what
white people need to watch that right
here yeah it's for white people to learn
but i think a black audience is like
yeah we get it
yeah like can we just have a black adam
sandler you know
that's what we're going to get to i feel
like you know we're in a phase where
a lot of like the the horrific black
moments are being highlighted but
i do feel like there's going to be a
transition toward just
you know more fun atmospheric types of
uh
black films we got to make that
transition yeah and i want to talk about
just your influences for a second
because um when you were talking about
your animated show
i wonder chosen did you watch that
oh god was one of my favorite like i
feel like we have a similar
like you know nerd um like i used to
watch animaniacs yeah
dude i have like a collection of
animations lunchboxes and stories
you know i'm on a list to um reboot it
but i think they just did with hbo max
or something
i don't know oh for hulu i was on a list
starting tenure it's the first spec i
ever wrote
when i was 18 i wrote like a script for
animaniac i didn't know what i was doing
and uh do you remember pinky in the
brain and like yeah like i did the whole
and then there was the girl who came out
the cra
it was interesting because it was for
adults and kids simultaneously like if
you go back and watch
it now you're like dude these are all
like hollywood references that we would
still get now
deep cuts i think that in a weird way
was my first like
i'm studying hollywood and i want to
understand how this business sure i mean
i think
our first same for us with roger rabbit
yeah who
when we first saw that movie we were
like oh hollywood is like because it's
all colorful and you have the cartoons
and the animation and we were just
enamored with hollywood at that point
right and then animatics sort of
solidified our
obsession with it whoa that's nuts
yeah so we've always had like a
fascination with hollywood yeah it's
also
just like in wacko's whack i was like we
weren't even saying wack yet
like it was like there was a lot of shit
that you go back to and you're like what
um but uh that was big like what else
like growing up was like
you feel like we loved like uh
fresh friends seinfeld you know chris
rock
dave chappelle wanda sykes uh
you know the steady stream of tv sitcoms
uh i already said right richard pryor
eddie murphy you know just
david i said redbucks yeah larry david
just
you name it we were and then what about
dramas were you watching dramas is
[Music]
we didn't really like get into like like
cinema cinema
until high school we had a buddy uh he's
well he's still our buddy by the name of
the son
nigerian guy who was uh really really
into cinema and kind of like
schooled us on on what's like what's the
best films
in my brain and i hate that my brain
does this but you know when you first
watch a movie you're like oh this
reminds me like city of god was like the
first thing i thought
of when i th those like opening shots i
was like this i haven't felt like this
since i saw city of god
in terms of the way that it shot the
lighting the
the the um just the authenticity because
again like
we're in this business like you're like
oh that's where they put the camera oh
that's a light that's not the moon that
it was like
i i felt like uh i wasn't watching a
movie and it's so
hard for me to city of god was one of my
like big sort of like
oh yeah when i watched it for the first
time i was blown away huge influence
huge influence just it's mastery in
terms of just like
editing and editing and the direction
and the acting i mean a lot of those a
lot of the actors were first-time actors
wow so which is crazy and they filmed on
location
and it's just like a lot just like went
into to making that film and it's
timeless mm-hmm
and i don't know i just love it but why
i said when was that first time we
watched it our sophomore year of college
sophomore year of college was the first
time we saw it what's this on we were at
princeton doing like an internship
and we watched fellowship fellowship and
we were watching we watched that one and
we watched oh boy
and i was like whoa oh whoa this is like
this
is hitting me in the chest like i feel
this isn't like silly because you know
americans
american cinema has come a long way for
sure it has been very deeply influential
and deeply influential you don't get
sick
and i think the rise of documentary are
people watching documentaries so much
it's raising the bar for movies based on
you know what i mean like you have to
feel as real or else that's
compared to the documentary he's going
to feel fake it's just like but it just
was so i was just like this is
like i'm uncomfortable and i should be
right right that's exactly how i felt
like this is making me feel
things i've never felt while watching
something but your own age
it's just so cinematic but they're
dealing with you know
poverty in brazil and these like high
level
social political issues but it all felt
so real
but it was so stylistic and i don't know
it's just a perfect film did y'all shoot
in chicago
no we shot him in cleveland cleveland oh
nice and then um
were there any like happy accidents that
had like you know
they say there's the movie you may write
the movie you shoot in the movie you
make or something
i don't know what hack said that but was
there anything because you know when
you're
making a movie i mean you y'all did it
in a very different thing but i
like people fall out people this they
can't do it anymore the actress gets
pregnant she won't do it and like
it feels like the worst thing in the
world but then later you're like oh my
god like
it was actually not falling apart it was
falling into place were there any like
happy or you're shooting and you're like
we're losing light we can't shoot
everything we can shoot over here and
now
this won't be in it that we like was
there any like happy hour you know we
had the panthers on set we had uh
we have fred hampton jr like literally
on set every day
sort of critiquing the script and
critiquing the scenes and so there were
moments when like
you know you write the scene and you're
like oh it's going to be dope and
you know i we want to shoot it this way
we want to shoot it that way and then
transgender he's like well that's not
happening so one scene was uh
the final one of the final set pieces
where the cops sort of
you know bust in and shoot up the place
and our initial sort of uh
way of having it was for the cops to
sort of swing in hollywood style and go
through the windows and you know make it
a real like
uh like and i still think it's a great
set piece but we wanted to make it even
more hollywood
yeah and uh uh for hampton jr on the
advice of mama cool
she he was like you know we got to scale
that back because that's not what
happened
you know it was a little bit more matter
of fact they came through the doors they
shot and then they you know what i mean
like
and and and and at the time i'm like no
no no we got to make this shit big in
hollywood but now i'm like no you're
right
get that realism because that's going to
make the audience feel it even more
100 it's not sexy because no no no like
oh it's such it's the right instinct but
you know to do to go we need to make
this as compelling as possible but how
bald in a way it was and how like oh
yeah this isn't the the super um
i think something super like what would
you call it acrobatic
like that would have been like oh now
i'm watching a hollywood movie no this
is someone's fucking life yeah
and this is climactic and anti but
anticlimactic and how just regular you
know
not sexy it feels yeah there's so many
like physical constraints
to shooting that scene if you want to
you know capture the realism of it
uh having cops swinging through that's
just not
you know i mean you could yeah an
audience was gonna be oh that didn't
happen yeah and also like we've seen
cops
they're not yeah you know what i mean
there's something but they're not
athletic
they're not they don't have to swing
because they already conspired so hard
that they wouldn't have to have planned
all that hydration
like it was already sure it was already
it was already done before it was done
all they had to do was go through the
motions right it was already planned so
it was very methodical so you know like
you said it just went through the
motions
another aspect of the film and i think
shaka said this somewhere but it was
like during the edit
you know you know when you're editing
the film you that's when you're really
making the film right you get all these
get all this footage and you're trying
to figure okay so what's the best way to
shape this
and i think the first cut we saw um
it was very like william o'neill
dominant you know because that's
that was the initial pitch that was the
initial story it was
going to be mostly william o'neill and
you know we got we had that first cut
and people weren't really
you know reacting too well to it because
of the fact that it was
too much william o'neill but how do you
start i mean how do you ascertain if
someone's reacting well or not
because it's you should be like this
hurts this is hard to watch
i think shaka um you know he invited
several of his like friends filmmakers
who were friends and then they gave him
not just random focus room they gave him
like some some specific notes on
what was working and what wasn't working
and so after that
the first cut you know we they started
to reshape it where so dominique got
a bit more a bit more screen time
it did i remember seeing her for the
first time in the
jamie foxx movie probably project power
yeah yeah which is a wild movie
that's crazy but she it's so she
grounds it in a way that i like i'm by
by this hook line
it was just like and that's what she did
with our films right right right she has
an uncanny ability to like just
ground the story emotionally where you
feel what she's going through and she
feels real
you know she feels it doesn't feel like
she's acting you really see
actresses like her you know on screen
like
in a way that you know she was utilized
in our film and so like
i think it was important to make her a
more prominent character throughout
uh and i think that again that was
pretty accidental like even when the
first script was written you know
you know the the uh deborah character
wasn't as pronounced as she should have
been
and i think that's a testament to you
know like you know
there's men writing for a script and
sometimes when we write
uh female characters they're either thin
or they're not like fully
developed so oh they've been physically
thin i was like no
no they're just like they're not savage
they're not actualized yeah
yeah because we're just dimensional
right for so it was it was a process
that we had to go through with the
studio they were like no do this at more
of that and it was like okay we'll do
that we'll do that and then eventually
you know i think she became a more fully
actualized character through that
process
right right and then even in the edit
you know being able to utilize her a bit
more
to again make the film a bit more
emotionally rich
because you're just coming from the
perspective of will and he's dominating
every scene you're going to lose
that emotional connection to the
audience because the audience hates will
right there's nothing he can do yeah to
make them feel any sort of
empathy for empathy or sympathy for him
so being able to utilize
dominique in that regard uh just allowed
for us to open up and she brought out
chairman fred's character she made him a
more complete character and their
dynamic
uh just made the film more complete and
then what is the name of um
the i'm just blanking uh jesse plemmons
why is he so good at being a racist
with jessie plemmons like i just was
like
dude like cut like i mean
when you can just settle into that role
like it's just
it's such a service right you know but
like did you watch this
process he's a master at just like he is
he the next phillips
hoffman i feel like he might be he's a
master at conveying
uh a sinister character but in such a
like a sort of a
boy next door kind of way where you're
just like man you're so creepy man
eating potatoes
he always like there's a justification
to his heinous actions that you kind of
buy
like and it's like i shouldn't be buying
this this is crazy
he's a sociopath but like i'm buying it
because of the way he's selling but he's
also
plotting the murder of the black man
like
you know what i'm saying so it's like
you have to be i can't like you too much
but
i have to like you enough to where
you're able to convince all these people
you have to have a charm
obviously you're able to get away so
that's the thing about that it's more
effective
you know you see like oh it's not some
cartoon
racist who's trying to i mean he's
definitely trying to
corner this black kid but in a way that
isn't dumb it's a way it's a way that
hasn't been seen before in film where
normally it's
again a cartoon racist yeah using all
his power to cause
uh a black person to do something with
this it's like it's
banality of evil it's a it's a guy who's
seemingly good
using all the tools of persuasion to
commit a very heinous act
i just thought it was such brilliant
casting because it's like to show
monsters as only like the reason they're
able to get away with all this because
they're charming and they're funny
and they can like sort of talk to people
make them feel special you know the way
he was like ah if you want the good
right like you're like get in the top
like it's just it
those are the people that are the
problem you know what i mean
yeah yeah those are the people yeah
those are the people you need to be uh
more fearful of you know but to have
written him as like just the perfect
balance of
a monster but one that would actually
get away with his monstrous acts
yeah you know and being so convinced
like that was was there anyone else
in consideration for the casting that
part i think we all wanted i love that
he's just like oh so i just get straight
off first for racist now
got it i i think i won
i definitely want it uh jesse genius
from the beginning it's total jesus uh
i just felt like that dynamic with la
keith would be stellar
still i was and they were the tension
it's almost like
sexual tension it's the way that that
that you know jesse's character is just
sort of like preying on him in a way
that is so
dehumanizing right you know it was just
like it was just so bone chilling to
watch
and it didn't he didn't give you a
second to
not feel it right right right his
presence is always
looming illumina on on uh leki's i mean
bill o'neil and that's what like what's
so crazy about cointelpro in general is
like it's a lot of
hoover was obviously a monster yeah but
everyone else not everyone else but a
lot of the other people that i've read
about like the william sullivan's like
he was the third in command the fbi when
they were doing all that crazy shit
like they were just intellectuals they
were you know family men or
and they were they seemed like you would
meet them and think oh they're not
virulent racist they're you know they're
just hard-working guys
taking care of their families and but
they there's such a like a an
intellectualizing process where they go
through where they're like no this is a
justification these guys are a national
security threat and they have to die we
have to neutralize them right
and it's like weird to see them have to
like rationalize
what they're doing the cognitive
dissonance that has to happen they're
like oh these people are like the clan
yeah they're it's like it's sort of and
it's sort of like it reminds me of
you know just like the big lie like when
someone in power tells you something
that is so ins
if you just used a second of critical
thing but then you're like well you must
know where you're at
it's like the reason we still see a cop
and we're like we need it's like yep
you know it's just like it's in you're
supposed to do the
how could someone in the fbi be doing
the wrong thing exactly
it doesn't make any sense like
people look to them and they think that
they're doing the right thing because
there must be someone that would have
this in charge that would like someone
would have caught this by now like it
just like doesn't make sense and it's
too disorganizing to the brain and i
think it's a lot of times why
like in human nature we have to like tap
out or disassociate when we
hear stuff like this and it's so
important to have like super challenging
movies where you cannot look away
because we're like oh the fbi killed
black and you're like
that's too much right right you know
what i mean what else are they doing
are we are we in mk ultra okay are we
all experiments are we aliens are
innocent like it just is like opens a
door
to being like none of the walls are
right solid right
and i think you know a part of us was
like you know we want to present a story
that
is conspiratorial in nature but it's
like there was a conspiracy to commit
murder so it's like yeah well you should
question
what your government's doing with your
tax dollars to citizens because if you
don't
they're just going to keep getting away
with this stuff you know what i mean
also if i may just
uh for the people that haven't seen the
movie or or um like missed this part
you know hampton was building schools
and
you know and and feeding chill like like
the
the fact that he was able to be
ascertained is like a threat right
was just like how did that well that's
why he was a threat because he was
trying to
to build uh build up the community and i
think
i think that that was uh uh hoover's
biggest fear like
this guy's actually putting forth a plan
that's going to bring people together
right
like it's a serious and then being
together
you know the gov and the government
wants to have a uh sort of a monopoly on
services like they're
they're the ones who want to provide
medicine and health and
you have other people saying no we'll do
it then you're like oh you're saying
like the mafia yeah yeah
you're like where the where are the
people this is how we control that right
we need you to need us in order to
control you
need us now we're it's all about uh
sustainability for the government
and there's also i mean going back i
grew up you know uh mostly in washington
dc
where you know i grew up you know seeing
uh
marion barry who i did did crack and
then got reelected
like we you know but watching people go
like no we trust this person
even though he's doing crack because at
the time so much
ostensibly like like when you grow up in
dc or i i you know
and i'm sure in every city it's a
different thing but you start to learn
about stuff that's not in the history
books like
like the new deal and please you'll
correct me in the comics if i'm when i'm
wrong about this but like
the new deal like for as much like good
press as it gets there was a lot of
institutionalized racism
they built the freeway so i had friends
that
i went to school with that lived in
anacostia and like you couldn't get
there
it's like that in newark newark we have
a literally we were on first street
and there's a highway that goes right
there's a hospital built there and there
was a
highway spill cut right through so
people can get from the suburbs to the
city
fucking the the pollution and all that
shit so there's no way to stop by and
get a starbucks and then stop by at this
restaurant and then build
it also like help the drug trade so
people can just come in and out get
their drugs leave so it was a it was a
failure on many levels to build a
highway right through the
inner city and then just looking at that
and then i would you know i would go to
georgetown university and like
run on their track and then you realize
it's built by slaves you know it's just
sort of like
the kind of um the the number of things
we have to
actively ignore every day to get through
the you know what i mean
through the day it's easier it's like
i'd rather not think about all that sad
stuff
we're here now what can we do about the
sad stuff we can't go back and
retroactively change it
so what's the point in sort of keeping
it at the
forefront of our consciousness and it's
like the point of it is to
go through an honest healing process you
know we haven't done that yet in america
but i think it's a lot of a source of a
lot of the tension that we have as like
black and white people
and we haven't had done that inventory
with the traumas that we
and the fucking horrors that we've put
ourselves through uh
and i think that's why we keep repeating
the same mistakes and i also think that
we're in a
um a group of people who
probably know this i mean i i talk to
when i say that about georgetown talking
other people they're like what
like i mean it is like a lot of stuff
that you know uh we may know
um me knowing obviously a tremendous
amount less like most people are like
what like
they're not on they don't follow who i
followed instagram they're not in my
algorithm or whatever they're not
reading you know
or you know trying to um uh or don't
have the time
they're like what do you mean i have
three kids i have four jobs like i don't
i don't have time to figure out who
built georgetown university you know
what i mean i don't have time to study
the new deal
we covered that in school it was a good
thing moving on you know so it's like
there is this like
sort of pressure of like you know
keeping it top of mind
but what do you keep it top of mind
cause there's so much to kind of get
to um yeah and that just brings me to a
couple things and i know i have to let
you go at some point
um we're few you guys lost yeah yeah we
love you you're back to podcast
okay lost
[Laughter]
yeah so you won let's be honest this has
way more viewers than the oscars wait
no wait no no you're right i'm like this
is
okay so just in terms of like statues
coming down and you know
you know i um when amber riley was was
on
uh we were talking a lot about the um
history of experimenting on black women
and medicine and this like
you know stereotype that uh black women
have a higher tolerance for pain and all
that and there was that
gynecologist statue that was in central
park for the longest time who's
a gynecologist that experimented on
black women like it just came down
and it was the kind of thing where it
was like yes it should come down but
like
you know i mean it wasn't saying all the
horrible thing maybe it stays up and
you said horrible things he did like how
do you you know keep
this um or make sure that this is in the
zeitgeist that people understand
especially moving forward with like
distrust of vaccines and you know
whatever you know
and like what is the solution to that
yeah i mean i'm torn on the the tearing
down
stuff uh
because i feel it's important to
know the history and i feel it's
important to
you can't pretend like it didn't happen
right but could you move on could you
move it to a museum you can move into a
museum
you're right fair that version of the
statue was glorifying him like
a hero and eliminating the disgusting
stuff you know but does anyone see a
statue that's like we can't do this
again this guy's a
fucking well maybe maybe it is a way to
proper properly
contextualize who this person is and was
and maybe put up like a fuck
an ipad or something that gives you like
yeah what he really did yes you can now
take the statute and say oh
this is a complex figure is forcing me
to think about his
atrocities uh let me process that and
you know then i make a decision whether
or not i want this to stay up right
right
i feel like yeah we got to inform people
about the activities of the people that
we're honoring because you don't want to
honor someone of the monster
right right but i think there's just
again so much left out in the history
books where it's like you're like oh
yeah and like people are like oh yeah
tuskegee i learned about in that school
in school
like kind of but it's like as an adult
you need to re-learn about what
i mean as a kid you're like okay i think
i memorized a couple things and i'm
going to try to pass this quiz
yeah but looking at an as an adult
you're like the amount of people that
were involved
in doing this is so like it's
overwhelming
it's overwhelming but then it's like but
then it's like well how do you process
someone like george washington how do
you process thomas jefferson's name
these guys were
slave masters and it's like yeah that's
true but they're also
first president of the united states and
we have you know we can't like
seem like they didn't have an impact on
the history of america
so i don't think you should get rid of
those statues there's just so much to
uncover
and but for people of color to have to
do the work it's also like
yeah you know we shouldn't have we
shouldn't have the responsibility to do
it
yeah like that's it's like not only were
we victimized and brutalized but now
you're asking us to correct everything
and it's like that's just
putting all the responsibility on time
my thing is i can't can't i don't think
things can be corrected right no i think
i think you can i think you can have a
more honest portrayal of the history
sure so that's the correction i'm
talking about i said tearing down
or erasing but contextualizing and
giving it a more
uh authentic uh uh version of history
you can do that right that can be done
yeah i agree like someone should do a
history book that's like
that's not what happened you know that's
just no way that's the full story
this is what happened yeah like this is
like such a tiny sliver
from someone who lives like well we
should leave that part out you know it's
just so
there's just something that i get so
frustrated about like
you know the next generation of like
filmmakers of color and they're like
okay i just have to tell all the stories
that
haven't been told and do all the work
like again
yes like it's definitely a burden for
hampton story it was like
emotionally we invested a lot and it's
like but it felt like a worthy enough
cause to
make that sacrifice but like going
forward i'm like i don't know if i have
it in me to like
i feel like i think you got to get one
great story told
yeah i think we did our service yeah
yeah it's like
now can i go just be silly and i just
tell jokes for the rest of my life
prank movie like a jackass we're just
farting exactly like
we helped secure chairman fred's legacy
it's like
now i just want to tell jokes yeah and
be funny again and so you're gonna be
touring
oh yeah oh yeah um we haven't set
anything up yet but okay we're looking
into it now and just to try to figure
out like what's the
best spots to go to but you're on the
road right i'm on there i mean like
every weekend until
december basically sounds beautiful yeah
there was a time when like we were in
charlotte and
i think someone already knew a punchline
that we had done because he was a big
fan
and he was saying the punchline as i was
saying and i got like really mad and i
was like
get this guy i i don't even know what
this is pre-hollywood kenny you know
this is
don't get me started on how many candles
he needed so where
is my trailer next to his uh
chair or pillow on the floor he got i
mean i don't think we've known trailers
we had a trailer one day for sofia
vargara and then
the train the the train the the dragon
chair was broken and she fell through it
and we almost destroyed like the most
highly insured
like by health insurance ass oh my god
and yeah her ass was like in church
and she fell through it oh my god yes
and then
and then all her stuff was with dion
cole and they hadn't met yet yeah and
like it's
like building on an independent movie or
the meeting for the first time and then
all of a sudden you have to have been
married for eight years
chemistry um and she like threw the
chair out of the trailer just to get it
out
literally to move it and it like hit
diana
dion was like was she in a bad mood no
like we almost killed her
and then um yeah it was just like such a
shit show
[Music]
of all that hilarious anyway but yeah
you were a diva well i'll go
i was uh yeah so we're at the show
charlotte this guy's like finishing the
punch lines for us and i get i just like
losing him like you gotta get off
get this guy out here i'm like what am i
doing like this guy can't paid to see us
he's having a good time and he's just so
effusive he likes to say the punchlines
but it was a positive heck when it was
fucking me up
yeah i got real mad yes because i can't
comment now i just i'm like oh i realize
there's another muscle there it's a
dance with the audience and sometimes
you know they they want to be involved
and i think it's like i think they're
bumpy
they love being involved and i think
that it's uh it's it's crucial for the
comedian to be able to
to integrate that into the entire set
you know if you're able to like be a
little bit more open a little bit more
flexible in
the direction that you're going in
because our first five years we were
like we refused to talk to the audience
we were so just like
don't talk while we're talking well
because there was also this thing of
like it used to be
the people that paid our bills for these
sort of like
magical men and offices in that universe
or wherever it is and
you know like these guys that went to
like advertising school and now they
decide
you know whatever we were trying to
please like executives but now it's like
the audience really is your boss
that's it if you're a comedian and
podcasting it's not like i'm gonna
fucking shut you up so the executive
here from netflix is going to see my
hour it's like no dude you've you
you've supported me for 10 years they
barely have you know what i mean i'm
still on the fence with these people
every year i have to re-audition for a
job i already got you know
so it's like i go like oh right you guys
are my boss
and that's how the internet that's all
the internet and streaming is doing it's
it's continuously sort of cannibalizing
the the authority figures that we have
in the industry is telling us what we
can and cannot say to the audience
what's happening is like it's sort of
like what happened during
uh the printing press and with the
catholic church it sort of became
less of a centralization where you you
have your direct relationship with god
our gods as entertainers will always be
forever the people yeah they dictate
trends they dictate what they want
executives get fired they they something
else
comes along it's like that's an
ephemeral thing yeah the people
who matter and i think uh you're right
like what streaming in with standup is
like no you have to please these people
because if they don't like you they'll
just move on
and my and my new thing with performing
and i love getting back to clubs to
get this mindset set back which is like
my only job tonight is to make sure that
this group of people comes back next
time i'm in town
i'm not trying to like get a sh i'm not
trying to please everyone in the world
i'm not trying to like
appeal to china and all these quadrants
with you know streaming global now like
i'm just trying to make sure you guys
come back next year
when you see my name and go oh we had
the best fucking time last year and
we're going to go again
it's like pleasing your own fans that
you already have instead of trying to
get more of these like amorphous ones
that probably
if they were to fuck with you they
probably would have by now you know what
i mean so it's like
it's been nice to just see like human
faces and to see
real laughs at things that in la rooms
or
if i was just living on twitter i would
be like oh you can never say that
because there's this implication now
that audiences are so dumb
yeah like and being involved get it i
don't get it
because i was once a member of the
audience i don't think i'm done honestly
i'm just gonna get
cancelled um for that it's because a lot
of like harvard elite
nerds have been like running a lot of
these writers rooms and being in charge
of comedy for so long and there's been
this elitism of like we look down on
anyone that
you know has like a blue-collar job or
doesn't live in la
and just like you know and so i mean
i've been in so many of those rooms
right the audience will never get that
well they're never gonna get anything
because all we do is write dumb shows
for them so how are they gonna
you know it's just like it's so
frustrating um
to watch and it's just sort of like you
know
it it drives me insane how and they
don't want to see something serious they
don't want to learn about
you know they make so many assumptions
about what the audience wants but for
the most part i think people don't
really know what actual humans want
stand-up comedians we're out on the road
we're interacting with people we're
telling joker to laugh
directly it's like i think we have a
acutely we have a better understanding
of what people want right
i always get in trouble right with like
stuff around anything me too related
i don't always anything but i'm i'm
generalizing but
like when i talk to it's you know i did
this whole special on like sexual
harassment i was like okay this is
something i am qualified to talk about
like i try to stay out of politics or
just like amplify other people that know
more than me i'm not gonna like pretend
all of a sudden i'm like
an activist an expert politician and
political scientist just because i've
been telling dick jokes for 15. like
this whole thing where everyone's like
um knows what fuck they're talking about
yeah i'm like i'm a clown i'm still a
clown i'm just a fucking clown
you want to laugh come to me you want to
be told how to vote go to these people
that are inspiring
we're not social scientists we're not
going to follow don lemon follow neil
degrasse tyson for science follow
someone you know like
sort of like i uh what am i saying i
forgot oh you're talking about
uh uh as a comic do you love that you
just went from oscar
nominated writer to script supervisor
you gotta be versatile
oh no it's just the idea of like you
know when i did all these jokes on
sexual harassment right
the first stop on the tour was houston
you know and i'm going like sexual
harassment and it's you know this is bad
and here's why in the office like
why are men this woman in houston she
was like you know
45 or something she was like just take
the compliment and move on
and it was like you don't get to say
that's an invalid point she's just like
i have so many
the list and the list of shit i have to
deal with this doesn't break the top
hundreds of people in hollywood i mean
you tend to be
too sanctimonious yeah you lose sight of
like real people don't care about
the things that we care about have real
problems it's a privilege to be like
that guy looked at me weird
in the place i work where i have
benefits and health insurance and
get to work yeah and that's not to say
like we shouldn't have conversations
about sexual harassment
we have to have those conversations
because it's been uh you know
awful for many many years i think it's
just weird when like
you now you start to police what you
know if you're a comic and you're going
out there like
sort of preaching what people should do
is like
we're supposed to be the scumbags or
like or we tell st
we find a way to get people to think
about it um
and draw their own i just think telling
people what to think and lecturing as if
we
right right
i did drugs i dropped out of school i am
in no position right
right right you know you know tell
people how they should live right and we
should be able to comics have to be able
to say shit
that other people won't say and that is
starting to be taken away like we have
to say dangerous things we have to
be polar i like we got to play with fire
i mean that's what the comedians
we don't play it safe i mean we're we we
play with fire and i think
sometimes especially in this new age of
woke it's like it becomes
a risk now to be risky and uh i think
that it is affecting comedy but
i think i think we will prevail the
people that are like
nipping at the heels of the brave are
the ones that have never taken a risk in
their life
and really don't do stand up of course
it's a non-standoff
coming for us like when's this time you
did stand up like it were comics that
are just
yeah you know who are we like there's
there are people
a lot of people millions of people who
want stand up
yeah unfilter
you know something like it's our job to
sort of take them through a haunted
house
you know and um and then another woman
when i got to like the after meet and
greet thing
uh she was like you're gonna miss it
when it's gone
and i remember being like how charming
this texas woman
who's like you know take it while you
can't like enjoy what you can and sure
enough i was in new york like
a year later or something and i walked
back back past this um like big
construction site the whitney museum
which was being built and i walk by it
every morning
and um i i was like nothing
i remember just thinking like nothing i
guess like maybe i should wear
like i we have to be able to say our
first our gross thoughts
we have to be able to say all that out
loud and and i just
pretending you're perfect like there's
no comedy in that i agree no comment no
if you don't have flaws and if you don't
think gross shit or
do
yeah it's just not i get lots of offers
for ad people because sponsors
right i don't always say yes i'm very
specific could you keep saying yes and
then can i get a big
look at this paper you guys want to see
something real instead of a podcast host
who's just saying what's written on a
freaking
piece of copy i'll read that there are
shills
i carry athletic greens with me
for real i am on tour now i drink one
every more i put it in my water
sometimes i mix it with iced tea in the
afternoon
for a little caffeine boost i hope i'm
allowed to say that
we'll see and i put it in i actually
like to warm it up as like tea
also that might be weird when i'm at the
comedy club and i'm like chili willy
and then but look at this in look
two look two and by the way thank god
these don't you know when you normally
put something in your purse ten minutes
later it's exploded everywhere yep
it's not going to explode thank you
explode in my mouth where you belong
it's no wonder you love it because it's
contains 75 vitamins and miser
miserables miserable that's you right
now but also
[Laughter]
i love that you're just like i'm
miserable in this job sorry
i find it vitamins and miserable
vitamins and miserables
by the way you need athletic cream i
really do i haven't sat
up straight in 20 years you guys i'm
telling you
after covid i was going through some
stuff i was like not taking care of
myself
i got back on the cause alana glazer
turned me onto these a while ago
and then i was very frustrated because i
feel like rogan had this
everyone had athletic greens but me and
i was like how do we get athletic greens
you have to look healthy you have to be
a good spokesperson that actually looks
like they take care of themselves
um and so it's a very very big deal that
we got them it means
um that they think i'm healthy well i've
often said i wish i could just eat all
my
greens in one just one yeah you know
jetsons
yes yeah but bam but what lighter greens
and it also like
i like to do it like during a workout
like in the thing you shake it up it's
just like
it makes me feel less pressure
throughout the day because i'm not like
okay what do i eat i have carrots oh i
just had a carrot now i need to have a
wait am i not all the boxes not when
you've had your superfood powder
let's get to the actual copy one tasty
scoop of athletic greens contains 75
vitamins minerals
and whole foods sourced ingredients no
trash no multivitamin multimineral
probiotic and by the way thank you for
not being like
women's uh yeah totally like now you
know you know which is always like so
insulting this is like everyone can take
this it's not like
like gender specific yeah it's not like
patronizing right right
you need like extra stuff for your brain
because your brain is tiny you know
um uh fills all the nutritional gaps in
your diet increase energy and focus that
look how much energy
people think i'm like unbelievable
people are exhausted and people think
i'm like on adderall now
uh aids in digestion oh yes healthy
immune system
without the need to take multiple
products i also can't take a pill i gag
oh yeah oh yeah um right now athletic
greens
is at athletic greens.com whitney
enjoy and join and enjoy the health
experts athletes and health conscious
go-getters around the world who make a
daily commitment
to their health early day simply visit
athletic greens.com
whitney get your free your supply of
vitamin d and five
free travel packs and you know they
travel
yeah don't buy if you buy it from some
other website you're not gonna get all
that stuff
that won't be good for you
athleticgreens.com whitney
so i am obsessed with snacks i need them
at all times
i like to snack all day and uh
but i don't want to feel like uh like
you know when you like
go too hard on something gross and then
you just like hate yourself oh all the
time
i am this is what we have these are look
how many of these snacks we have
these we order them this is like for
real and i don't know if he knows about
me but my
mother ate pork rinds as a kid we are
from texas
okay that was like our main snack and
then you grow up and you're like this is
you're like gross when you find out what
it is that's so delicious
right but i can't eat it without feeling
guilty and
look at this pigless pork rinds as
someone that owns a pig
that named joe who i love like my own
child
and will not eat pigs anymore and it's
all look at i'm looking at the
ingredients right now
uh full of flavor free of guilt it was
made by this chef
uh dave anderson um who's like really
big in the plant-based
world yeah cause i feel like a lot of
people are trying to get in on the
plant-based thing right now and they're
just making
stuff that's unhealthy because a lot of
vegan stuff is not particularly healthy
it's just like full of like carbs and
trash you feel healthy because you have
them
because yeah you're just kind of like
you have no energy these i'm obsessed
with
and look i know they're probably really
loud and the people listening to me very
annoyed
there's texas barbecue nacho is my
favorite flavor all of these are free of
gluten
gmos artificial ingredients trans fats
cholesterol and soy and are certified
kosher
a lot of people don't know when you try
to go vegan or eat healthy a lot of it's
soy
right which is not so bueno all the time
i mean it's crazy and it's a
pla certified plant-based uh taking a
meal in a bag
puffs the first ever snack you can also
have as a meal
i love that as people that like
grew up just neutral grain bar right
yeah just like you totally everything
needs to be in one place we don't have
time to sit down for a meal it's awkward
that ship has sailed
dinner each bag has 21 grams of protein
has the nutrient of a multivitamin
including iron calcium vitamins b12 d
and e
which by the way you're like why don't
you eat vegetables because i just
learned when you cook vegetables they
lose all their freaking vitamins anyway
and you have to cook
yeah and we're women yeah we can't
um and so the fact that something like
on the
run is actually healthy we've worked out
an exclusive deal for good for you
listeners receive 25
off your first order go to
outstandingfoods.com whitney or use code
whitney at checkout to claim this deal
that's
o u t s t a n d i n
g f o o d s dot com slash whitney oh
they're on instagram too
fun follow us them you
i know i was trying to do uh write a
joke about um the neural
ink that's coming out you know it's like
the mind reading software
how it's like oh everyone's going to see
how sexist i am
because my first thought is like my
grandfather's voice or my
you know something old or something you
know gross or trauma driven or
competitive driven or like um from my
reptilian fear-based brain
you know because i totally do when a
female pilot walks on the plane there's
a little bit of a like
yeah there's a first and then you're
like no no no no no no nope she had to
work twice as hard to get half as far
she's probably even more you like have
to sort of um
undo your conditioning no i was on my
first time in my life flying
uh we had a black pilot and my i was
like oh shit you know right
i've never seen
what's going on well he was actually an
excellent pilot but it was like i was
like a little nervous in the beginning i
was like shit i'm
doing it i'm doing exactly what like a
white person might do like i'm nervous
at a brother
flying a plane this is crazy but it's
like but it's like
we just don't have enough data to
balance out that institutionalized
socially constructed shit you know
nothing happened to you can happen it
certainly could happen to the you know
the white guy who never had any exposure
to
when in reality when the white guy old
white guy walks on plane you should be
like well this guy's probably coasting
right right he probably got this job
just because he said i'll do it right
you know and the person that had to
fight harder and be like you know
it's probably the more quality like if
you think about like this statistically
most of the crash
airplane crashes are probably from white
dudes because it's more like
taking risks black pilots have crashed a
plane intentionally
zero white men have done it on purpose
you know what i mean we're still like
that's our guy
i gotta stick with him yeah it's like
it's like so i think you know
comics we say the ugly thoughts we all
have so that
everyone stops pretending they don't
fucking have them and they could do okay
like
they talked about it so now i can
address it i do that too and let me
fucking work around the comedians we cut
the tension you know
we try to try to speak as honestly and
truthfully as possible and
i think that that helps relieve tension
yeah when you're when you're trying to
shy away from that or pretending that
you're something you're not
uh it does make things more awkward and
keep things awkward but
i know comedians have a way of just like
cutting through that yeah like patrice
did it really well where he would just
say
those thoughts that everyone was
thinking he just said it
and you're like you're raping my time
yeah like that's a crazy thought but
also offensive
it's also the kind of thing that like in
my opinion women need to hear
so i was like yeah i'll talk to a guy
for three hours
and they're like all right bye and
friends you know what i mean it's sort
of like it was
like oh i needed to hear that that was
ugly and that but there's a reason it's
if it hurts me there's a reason why like
my ego is coming in i'm being defensive
there's something true about it right
yeah right yeah i like i'm like starting
to make my peace with offensive material
i'm like
life's offensive people are offensive
human nature is
history is offensive the shit that
people did our answer to
is offensive but like me bringing it up
like let's neutralize it let's work
through it so yeah we should have a
right to speak on it right i mean we
have freedom of speech and
we're comedians and i think it's our
duty to speak on these things so
yeah and if you're uncomfortable you're
you know we'll get up and walk out but
i'm also probably in a i'm probably
going to the right area
sure if you're this upset like there's
something here
you know assuming your intention is not
to actively be like sexist racist sure
sure sure you're not trying to harm
people you're just like i'm trying to
provoke
i would like you to come to the show
leave
with different thoughts sure that's what
we wanted to do with judas right
right we wanted to provoke a discussion
not just about police brutality but
you know being a black capitalist you
know in in the age of woke like
there are some contradictions there you
know where you're you're fighting for
justice but you're also trying to sister
yeah you know what i mean so
those are some of the questions we were
trying to get at with with the film i
mean
it wasn't just like the villainy of the
police it's like no there's a there's a
villainy to
capitalism there's a villainy to to
materialism which i might i must in a
way can be
the way to win because they didn't
they're not making another
black panther to do a favor because they
feel
how can we guilty another billion
dollars yeah so it's like just now it's
like becoming very clear
that these movies do really fucking well
so
now it's it makes me even more annoyed
sometimes because i'm like you didn't
change
you're still a greedy fuck you know
you're not doing that you're doing this
for the
well i think there was a study that i
think there was a study that said like
uh
you know hollywood loses like 10 billion
dollars annually by not
making uh settlements on people that
come forward settlements and stuff like
that
by not investing in like stories from
people of color you
you sort of lose money and it makes
sense yeah you're basically
denying stories for an audience it
doesn't all have to be like black trauma
porn it can be more nuanced portrayals
but
black panther wasn't like black panther
yeah it was just a universal story that
could be sold to
a mass audience and it's also just been
proven that um workplaces that are more
diverse
are uh more smoothly run and more
prolific and so it's like
when people talk about inclu inclusivity
right around stuff it's like don't do it
because you feel bad or
it's just going to make a better move
it's just going to make a better movie
it's going to be a more interesting
movie like having diverse writers rooms
i was like i guess we have to
it's like dude your show's going to be
better right like you're going to make
more money if you hire these people
racism is so economically unsound i mean
just think about it like
the nba keeping black people out you
basically you're basically saying we
don't want to make this a billion
dollars
and then you let black people win now
it's a billion dollar industry like
you're you're literally saying to
yourself you don't want money that's how
crazy it is that to me i would
rather yeah i'd rather not make the
money yeah
and stay racist it's weird
it's the same thing with like what we do
to women too like we keep them out of
their marketplaces like but that doesn't
make any sense well because also
remember the
um uh i know especially moms my new
thing is about like having moms because
moms know how to do 20 things at once
they know what to it's like the idea of
like we can't hire mom she's not never
going to be around it's like no she's
going to be like do you need some water
handling shit like dealing with people
that like crying ego like they know what
to do and i was like oh my god for so
long i was told like
or are shown like if you hire moms
they're never gonna be around they're
gonna have to leave early and it's like
no they just get
all the shit done by five that everyone
else would have gotten by done by ten
yeah
you know because they have somewhere to
go and their brains are just like
octopus brains
you know and so um yeah it is so uh it's
so
um hypocritical or what's the word um
self-defeating
counterintuitive power intuitive very
counterintuitive to do that but i think
it's like just getting more data and
more proof
um over and over again yeah that's how
you you can only like rely on the
numbers and say okay the numbers tell us
that if we do
x y will happen it's a benefit to us
overall so let's
you know trend toward that way and you
see what netflix and disney they really
like
invest in uh voices of color you see it
yeah
and there's they're so different from
every other major studio and they
generate
huge profits because they understand
that there's a market that you have to
ex you know
tap into to you know wring out the money
you should never close yourself off to
audiences
but you'll be surprised what they'll
want to watch and want to comment on and
want to interact with i know some people
complain about like
some of the some of the positions that
the world crowd takes in order to ensure
uh representation in front of him behind
the camera but i'm like i also believe
that
while some of the tactics are a bit uh
you know authoritarian i do believe that
the results are positive in the long run
in that you're expanding
the the nature of storytelling and
you're getting more diverse voices and
you're getting a more complex version of
narratives i think
that's good probably you probably have
to be that vigilant based on all the
barriers that were
put into place i mean you have to be
vocal about your your opposition to the
way things once were
and so i think that's why if sometimes
it feels a bit
they're authoritarian but it might just
be necessary but i also think it's
important that like just to sort of like
to nerd out on this angle because i've
spent a lot of time trying to like
figure out like what is
like what's happening you know and then
uh uh
internships used to be non-paid sure in
hollywood so only
rich people had the opportunity to like
shadow like rich people's kids had the
opportunity to shadow
the director and whatever and people
from other economic backgrounds are like
i can't intern for you for free i'm
gonna go work at a job
but they're not necessarily learning
about the business you know um
so i think like things like that that
you aren't sexy to talk about
you know like my cause was paid
internship you know what i mean but just
giving
um because in order to like intern for a
filmmaker to film company
or like you know an agency or whatever
you'd have to be able to pay for your
own apartment
move to l.a buy a bunch of suits and
then
that's 30. live rent free for three
months or just you know
most people of color from where we're
from they don't they will never have the
resources to do that
and it was just perpetuated like now
rich white people are telling all
stories now rich white people are doing
the jobs because they got the
internships
and it just is like a cycle of like you
know because the beginning of being a
artist of any kind is you're not gonna
right you're gonna have a ton of money
so
what's the what's the solution it's like
the solution is either you get more
people
in the traditional format you get more
people of color in in those spaces or
you try to take the process and make it
a little bit more palatable to people
who don't have
like very wealthy means like you you you
you make the process cheaper
you know what i mean how do you do that
with film can i last question just
because i like to do the dumb
questions that are like awkward and
uncomfortable and this might ruin our
friendship
um but uh you know i also see a lot of
awkwardness around this
where you know it's illegal to ask
someone's age someone's you know
background someone's
you know it's like there is a little bit
of like okay i'm trying to ask but i
don't know how to ask
like i'm not allowed to say like hey can
you send me all your black grips
or you're like hey are you black you
know so it's like i was trying to pitch
a um
and mike and i were working on it um and
uh i'm gonna work on it for free and not
get any credit just to sort of
you know what i mean an app that's
crew of color yeah that you can go
through and it's got the resumes and
anyone can submit so it's not just like
genius
but i um thank you and because there is
a thing about like you can't really
call up if you're a union production and
say hey we need
you know a best boy who's asian we need
it you know what i'm saying we need an
lgbtq
okay we have two more slots to fill they
can only be you know like it's illegal
to put in writing i believe
and so if there's a mechanism by which
we can take to you know make sure that
we're getting the
the the representation that we want
behind in front of the camera yeah like
how do we all do without like
being like i can't put this in writing
or i can't ask for this or now i'm
racist
and then the shame of being like i don't
know any black grips
and i don't want to admit that i don't i
don't know any black grip yeah i'm not a
group
yeah but yeah when it comes with like
people don't want to admit they don't
know you know it's just like
turns into just like a shit show so i
was just trying to like take some of the
shame out of it and i don't know how to
do it because
i there's so much talent out like some
clubhouse which is
you know i just feel like as imperfect
as it is and chaotic as it can be and as
like
people trying to figure out what the
ultimate point yeah
you know how to make it work for you i
just started like doing these rooms that
were like okay
where are you located why can't i hire
you like how come i don't know you
because i don't have the union hours and
like i don't know anything i don't have
an agent but in order to get an agent i
have to have a job and
a job i have to have an agent it's just
sort of all these like so many barriers
so many barriers that so i just was like
okay let's just send
set up a thing send your resume to this
email we'll start going through it
i'll just start sending it to show
runners like you know it's this um
it's gonna be an imperfect very sloppy
uncomfortable solution
i think that's why i think like the
development of atlanta could be a good
thing like maybe like
maybe we don't have this we have a we
have a place where black hollywood can
thrive
you have hollywood which you know
traditionally white but they work and
they co-mingle and they share resources
and
you you get jobs for black people so
you're pro segregation
a way yeah let us try it yes
separate but equal but like actually
give capital to black people like let us
like really play with the capital in a
real way and let us like invest in
production and see what comes out of it
there was an interesting argument it was
it
i don't know if it was like vassar sort
of one of these like very
forward-thinking schools
where a lot of the students of color
wanted to have their own
like fraternity and their own sorority
you know and
basically they were like that's
segregation you can't do that
but it was like it was self i mean they
were like we're going to segregate
ourselves anyway yeah
i was like i'd rather not be with this
nightmare
you know let me hang out whoever i want
to hang out with and it's just they just
so happen to be
all black people and this is the way you
guys stop being annoying and we'll come
hang out with you
how about you stop complaining that
you're out of almond milk
yeah but yeah so that is a very that is
fascinating
i'm saying look i believe in commingling
i think there should always be
interaction between the races i feel
like
but when it comes to hollywood and like
the the capital requirements to make a
film
we black people in front of him behind
the camera we need like a serious
investment we need like a collection of
individuals committed to the output of
black film like
people color people of color not just
black people but uh yeah and women too
so i feel like yeah
if if there's that sort of recognition
that we can be studio heads
we can be we can be somewhat in control
of the means of production like
if we can be a studio head you've
actually actually made
movies what would you no studio heads
have to have never made a movie never
have written a movie never
performed never have acted i think
you're overqualified
yeah right your job is just to send
emails that say circling back
right right yeah that's right the yeah
copy
where do we get the capital to make our
own stuff byron allen
baron allen yeah i'm not joking yeah
he's amazing i'm not joking
i'm obsessed with byron allen uh did you
hear him on the breakfast club his
interview on the back breakfast
i haven't listened to it he's he's a
remarkable guy though i'm obsessed with
him because in the beginning it was sort
of the joke was like oh myron allen like
he does these shows like
the comics unleashed where we're sitting
around or whatever and you know comics
our job is to criticize
everyone invite the hand that feeds us
the only person that's giving us spots
we're like there's a shark in the tank
we just have to like yeah you know um
and
he i mean gave me one of my first sort
of jobs you know he was doing these like
hosting
shows hosting comics meanwhile he was
giving them i mean
half the more women he was giving he
gets no recognition for any of that she
was giving women
tv spots when i couldn't get on
letterman because they were like can you
say your uncle instead of your dad and
i'm like why
like this has worked for two years why
are you making me change it all right
you can't say god you have to you know
you can't say your vagina you have to
say you're huhu or you're chi-chi or
something it's like
um and byron was just booking comics
like giving them beautiful tapes
um shooting i mean hundreds of episodes
a year
and um and then hired me for something
and i went in and i and i spoke to him
for a while for three hours he changed
my life he
told me in your stand up like stop
trying to please everybody just only
talk about what you're qualified to talk
about
that's the only way you're gonna not
have people steal jokes like he just
made me
because i was like i'm gonna talk about
airplane food and um right
religion and dating and everything and
i was also trying to neuter myself i was
like i can't be a girl no one likes that
and i was trying to like stay away from
it he's like just what are you doing
to you and then he also explained to me
in order to be like a dane cook at the
time you only need a million people
to come buy tickets which is like way
less than you would maybe think
and then he um fixed my credit
swear to god i couldn't get an apartment
i couldn't get a car and he was like
call this guy and he fixed my credit
jesus oh wow yeah
and he's starting to like finance movies
and you know basically
shooting tv shows on spec right he'll go
i'll pay for a season of this
right and then we'll go sell it yeah
he's there
yeah unique guys like that like money
guys who
will get behind you know voices who are
typically marginalized but your remind
your that
idea reminds me because he had to think
out of the box because he was like okay
so
uh i'm gonna give all these agents and
managers all my money how am i ever
gonna make money you know so he started
basically
um the way he uh built his business was
he would go to press junkets and
interview
people you guys done a million of those
by now and you
the journalists only get three questions
uh uh not me i get three hours
because what choice where are they gonna
go um i have nine pit bulls waiting on
the other side of that door
i dare you yeah he took um
he used those questions instead of the
corny questions you probably get were
there any pranks on set
like what was it like working with
daniel whatever and what you answer over
and over again
he would ask questions for him for his
own purposes he would say
what's your favorite meal to prepare at
home uh tell me about your pet
tell me all about your puppy yeah and
what's your favorite travel destination
and then after he got enough of them he
would cut them together on like
a vcr he got on his credit card yeah and
make specials that were
celebrity pets you know celebrity travel
destinations
favorite travel celebrities favorite
gourmet cooking and made these specials
that he sold
one-on-one with no agents no managers uh
to
like locally syndicated uh stations
and he went for the midnight to the 5am
spot
everyone else was going for the 8pm the
night he was like you're gonna have less
competition here
and this i'll be on all night the
security guards the people that are
overnight we're getting
nurses right there's people that are up
you know and basically started owning
that spot
and had nobody take any part of the
money because if i give this to an agent
or manager i'm just not gonna get any
money
they're gonna take my idea they're not
gonna take me seriously whatever and he
just did it himself and it's like
you know so when you say let's go to
atlanta and build our own thing it's
like yeah that's the kind of thinking it
takes i think
i think that's what it's gonna take to
really have a thriving black cinema
that's not
uh always sort of controlled by
uh you know hollywood who who are going
to necessarily say well we have to
make this appeal to a wider audience and
so we're going to limit
you know how we make this and i also
think that that
and then i have to let you guys know i'm
just now releasing all my resentments
about because also
no one wants to talk about the unsexy
stuff so when actress is going down the
red carpet and they're like i showed up
and there were
no people of color it's like yeah they
were they were hired six months ago
like you're just showing up you know
what i mean and um they've been hired
out they've
turned on other jobs you can't just
fight you know it was like it's a it's a
crazy situation but the
the line producers who actually really
do those
below the line we call it hiring
decisions and
it's interesting because i was talking
in this clubhouse room and i was like
why well you know why aren't there more
line producers of color
like you know it's like why is that yeah
i mean you don't i mean you tell me
i mean i think i know more about the
black experience um uh
but please explain to me why basically
we were talking to these um uh these
like college kids are like tish and nyu
and stuff and i was like is there like a
line producer program or you know for
you know kids that maybe want to be in
entertainment but are more into
economics and
you know finance but they don't really
want to be writers that would you know
sort of be able to curate
what a production would look like you
know it's just i think it's kind of a
thing where
no one says like hey oh instead of you
know going into being an accountant it's
like what about being a line producer
it's just not something those jobs
aren't like presented as like uh
viable like it's like no be a doctor be
a lawyer yeah
uh you know be a dentist yeah these are
attainable achievable goals then you're
going to get a certain salary
but when you talk about hollywood you're
like what are you saying
you mean some days you're going to work
and then some days you're not it's going
to be it's going to be
like yeah like transitions like what do
you mean you don't you're not going to
have a steady
salary yeah yeah how do you sell that to
it but to me like
like line producers of color control
like the future of and casting and all
that yeah
yeah all of it yeah it's largely white
because it's like the people that get
you know because it's like inclusion
right are great and then the line
producer is like okay where do i find
all these people to make it inclusive
you know and it's like
bringing you know like just i just feel
like i'm always trying to bang that drum
of like you don't have to be a writer to
be in hollywood you don't have to you
know if you want to come make an impact
in hollywood in some way if you're like
we're going to be an accountant or be in
finance like come be a line producer
right guys
i think i think what we've got to do is
like we gotta we gotta have the jay-z's
the oprah winfrey
yeah the billionaires out there say
finally say like look
we have the candy challenge billionaires
out there
we gotta we got the money like we got
the capital let's and we've got to wait
to raise the cap and we have a way to
raise capital you have the internet you
can raise money
in no time so it's like we have the the
means let's
let's take a risk also i'm gonna be
annoying
um uh as my dog knocks over my single um
honestly fair but is
starting a podcast and making money off
the podcast then all of a sudden like
yeah do you guys want to start a podcast
or no uh
i just want to make sure it's a it's
something that i can like really stick
my teeth in right yeah
and that i have something to say it's
like yeah i don't want to just
do it for the sake of doing it because
everyone else is doing it i want to make
sure like it's a good idea that
that's right totally totally and it's
like whatever it is but like
the amount of money that is being made
right now
is it a lot yeah really i mean
look at me look how it drives i mean i'm
obviously making a ton of money
um no but it's you know it's just like
it's right now is such a
and it's just and i hate to add another
obligation to your like
voices of color we need more of that but
like when they are on it's like yes like
i think a lot of people are like yes i
need to learn all this but i don't know
where to learn it i don't know who to
listen to
like i'm still getting biased
information from people that are like
performative activists and like right
mostly white people are talking about
this problem because black people give
you my free labor right i don't need to
talk about this
it's your job to learn but it's like
having uh you know
a podcast where it's either about you
know that kind of stuff or not at
all yeah you don't feel like it's like
taken away from stand up like do you
feel like
how do you balance your stand up with
your podcasting i know i see a lot of
people doing it very well it's
interesting
uh uh i don't think i'm particularly
funny
when i'm not doing stand-up right so
it's maybe
um i think the main thing i'm gonna say
is that because i think i am
a like verbal diarrhea over sharer it
makes people just more connected to me
when they come it's just like the meet
and greets are longer
yeah people have like letters and like
it's just more of a like
i have to really nail this because these
people have given me three hours a week
you know if there's there's no like
notebook where i'm like what else is i'm
just like i'm fucking
gonna deliver yeah but are they like
listening to you like a comedian though
like when you go up there now
i mean as a podcaster it's like it's
more free form so it's like do they have
an expectation for like
punch lines right now do they want you
to be more conversational well that's an
interesting i think i
already needed to be a little bit more
conversational so this has helped but
it's also helped me be more economical
in a way because i'm like that's a
different thing here i get to say
this one thing four different ways i do
that because i wasn't hurt as a child
and i'm like keep saying it over and
over again in different
iterations um it's like you have a
microphone people see you and they hear
you're literally being recorded
and filmed um but when i go on stage
it's all about ah we gotta lose those
two words uh
so it is i have to get more surgical and
write stuff out
because i'm like oh i can't just bank on
blathering
right because it's now you know because
when you take two words out of the setup
all of a sudden you know you get an
applause break
you know so i appreciate it makes me
appreciate stand up more in a way
because i i love leaving and going i
know what happened
yeah i know why that worked i know it
didn't work whereas this i never fucking
know right
i'm like why did anyone listen to that
and then the one i think is great i'm
like no one that was
that didn't do as well it's the one
where i fucking was
slurring yeah you know so it's weird it
has shown me that
their imperfection is and authenticity
is probably the best way to go
regardless oh yeah it's also forced me
to be
more honest in my stand-up because i
used to kind of cheat i'd be like oh
this guy i'm dating and everyone's like
we know you're dating this guy
you know like i just went through a
breakup they're like a year ago
you know so you can't be that right
you know it forces you to be more
specific right right what percentage of
the audience would you say is like from
from podcasting versus like
pure stand up that's such a good
question and uh
i don't know if i know totally know the
answer because i think once
you also get people from being guests on
other people's podcasts there's a lot of
people that show up
they're like i love you on rogan and i'm
like oh thank you and they're like you
have a podcast and i'm like
yeah or like bobby lee's podcast or
tiger b you know those are big podcasts
so it's like you know
they'll know me from other people's or
h3h3 which is what i do a lot that's a
youtube one
loves htc oh really oh gosh that's so
cool
they're my friends now i love them i
didn't really know about them before
well she she found out about you from
really that's just
not from watching the female brain wow
she doesn't watch anything it's not a
screening uh it is now on hulu so
i know what you all are doing tonight
i'm watching the first four minutes
please when you in 80 years i hope
that's your in memorial
in the oscars it's just you like
watching
dude why don't they have a prank in
memoriam they should
let's like lighten the mood a little bit
yeah like when it's like um
robert daddy jr it should be from like
shaggy everyone's most embarrassing
i think that's funny that's hilarious
and then um uh
uh now i'm being i know why i'm not
being asked to host ideas like that
um was it with the frances francis
mcdormand i'm obsessed with right
she's just like wild oh my god it was
like seeing
you know you had she had an aura you you
i've watched her since i mean fargo was
like the first time i
came in in contact with her and to see
her in person
i was just like i just want to just want
to talk to you and i i was obviously
like
i i was star struck i was legitimately
star strong
and then when she went up and hound was
that like what was like
so i did a little bit more research so
apparently uh the editor of the film
died his last name was wolf and so she
was howling
to pay respect to the editor right well
that really ruins my skit
just really ruin my skin strike it from
the yeah
you never heard it it's not as funny now
but i but sorry no i'm glad no now i'm
processing it and i'm going oh my god
because when i first heard it i was like
i saw wolves when i my dad died
now i have something to talk to fran
about when i meet her okay got it okay
cool
we just became closer yeah but like
she's um i you know
her at the you know last oscars or was
it two oscars ago when she talked about
the inclusivity writer it was like
like when something like that happens
are you like thank you or you
is is what is that not thank you like or
is there like a no
finally yeah yeah i think you want
voices like like
she's an institution she's well
respected in the in the in the in the
industry
she's also a torture force and as a
producer
so you want you want her speaking out
yeah and she was doing it before it
became
popular to do it because it's always my
question of like do you want
like are hollywood i mean she's like a
you know
not i wouldn't put in the pool of just
like hollywood people it's like is
are there certain people when they talk
you're like okay we don't need your help
yeah like you maybe know you know yeah
for francis i take i take
i take her seriously i listen to her and
i i feel like clearly not for likes and
no not performative she's not
yes it's not self-righteous she's like
raw and honest and
like to give chloe the the space to
create that film and to stand behind her
and to be sort of like 100
like for her campaign and you can just
see that she's
100 committed to like getting voices out
there that aren't traditionally heard
and it's in in using your power and and
i've you know been talking to some
like more famous actresses um uh
that you can say i'm i need
half of the makeup and the trailer to be
black on right you can't i only request
pat mcgrath or this a power-up like
black owned like
you can do that absolutely do it you
know so i think it's like
when i see a lot of actresses just being
like guys like where are like what's
going on with this like
10 years after the you know damage has
been done or whatever it's just sort of
like this is why
the number one through four on the call
sheet you can decide a lot
about what goes on the most powerful
people in hollywood are the white and
white and white actors and actresses i
mean especially the ones at the top of
their like and you can say i want to
shoot here i want to shoot downtown i
want to shoot in this area
i want to shoot in atlanta like do
something you know with that power and
it's like no skin off your back
i mean look what brad pitt is doing i
mean he's he's taking he's
yeah he's working with a lot of jeremy
kleiner who is
like i mean he's moonlight they did yeah
yeah yeah i've done a lot of films uh
from filmmakers of color and i think
that that's
i think that's a good test case of
someone who's in a very powerful
position
using that power and it doesn't amplify
uh and it doesn't impact his star power
at all
no he's still you know making
blockbusters he's getting oscars he's
still
he's still operating in the very high
level brad
pitt space that you he can only achieve
yeah but to take some of the time that
he has to
amplify other voices yeah i mean that's
that's what i'm talking about that guy
is probably one of the most powerful
people in hollywood but he's using that
power
too and not a lot of people even know
that that's the other thing it's like
don't do it for
uh uh you do it when no one else is
watching yeah right
it's like don't just do it for like
instagram or you know whatever like when
i see someone instead just taking
pictures with people of color and
i'm just like don't take that picture
just go do the work yeah do the work
yeah so it's like he's someone that's
not like every time he does the least he
can do
he's like look at this thing i did i
deserve a joke people were mad that he
was
in 12 years of slave like he's always
saved him like yeah but he paid for it
i know i have to let you guys go this is
great i want to come back can we come
back
i love you i wouldn't i will i would die
to have you come back i
already spent um the first couple
minutes i was with you off camera trying
to convince you not only to move
to l.a but to move in my home yes yes
you gave us a heart attack
you have to watch anyone knows i will do
that i do not have someone for that i
hope that's okay
hi there well you asked me to move and
watch your windows
[Laughter]
um and then uh and then you're going
back to new york but in terms of la new
york you kind of commute
yeah yeah we're gonna be back out here
uh we're shooting something for complex
yeah we're doing it at the comedy store
actually oh when i don't know when
it gets either late summer or early fall
oh wow yeah it opens up uh this week
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah let me know if
you want to do so when do you leave we
leave tomorrow
okay but we're going to be coming back
but there's also some last time okay
last last
observation is that we spent
you live here now we spent all this time
two years before going everyone in
hollywood is a scumbag everyone
hollywood's a sexual predator
everyone in hollywood is racist
disgusting and then we're like you need
to listen to
us
we all knew about harvey you need to
listen to us yes jeffrey epstein
financed every movie i've ever done but
listen to me when it comes to voting so
it's like
hollywood people want to be these like
martyrs that like
call people and say how disgusting the
business is but then they want to go
you should listen to us because we're
the upstanding it's a strange
uh cognitive dissonance like on the one
hand you know you're you're recognizing
that this is a pretty creepy place in
the kind of a scummy place historically
but then on the other hand he's like but
not me
i'm i'm i think it's just like a tension
at all costs it's like oh i need to do
this for attention
okay now i'm gonna go on this train this
clickbait attention by any means
necessary
yeah yeah so if walk is in then i'm woke
i'd rather i feel like
rather go away it's like donald glover i
was what i'm just like
go away he goes away has his life
actually you know for
you know art to imitate life you have to
have a life has a life comes back and
just kills it like yeah
then not being worried about
disappearing or being aware of it i
think it was patton oswalt
i think i was reading somewhere where he
said like
a lot of times he gets material just
from living
like he doesn't feel like the best way
to grow as a comedian is to
not do comedy for six months yeah and
live
live for a little bit like i with this
judas experience is like
i got to operate in a space that i've
never operated in as a comedian and i
took some time just to like i want to
fully process it
now when i go back out on the road and i
i'm getting back into my comedy
hat i'm like i got something to talk
about i got like a lot of shit that i
could
like implement the new evolution instead
of like doing an impression of yours
because a lot of times we're just doing
an impression of ourselves like this
worked before
right just keep doing this keep doing
exactly what it is that's exactly and
then you don't evolve
you know i always feel like you know
people sometimes
say to me like your first special was so
different than your i'm like i'd hope so
yeah new life experience yeah like i
would hope that i'm more secure
and more controlled and less screaming
and less desperate and the jokes are
smarter like i'd hope so
and then when they're like oh this last
special was your best special yet i'm
like i'd hope
yeah yeah oh yeah i'm gonna do better
than that first one you're right better
than the previous one right yeah people
like your first special wasn't as good
as
the fourth one i'm like i would hope
yeah imagine if i peaked in my ear
but uh but yeah so i i just i think i
think the main thing
we've learned from the pandemic in terms
is that like we can dig deeper and think
about
anyone that hasn't spent this time going
who the fuck
do i want to be what do i want to say
right like how do i want to really
impact
how do i want them to feel when they
leave the theater you know right and
like
yes this is going to work but like am i
moving the ball down the field
yeah like i'm more committed than ever
now to like
just making people happy like i i want
to make people think but i just i
i want them to be happy like i want them
to come to my show and be like man that
was
a pleasant hour yeah like that was a i
went there i
laughed and it was fun and i want to
come back to that like it's like i
understand that now like before the
pandemic i was like
i had this mentality where it was like
you know like i it was like an
antagonistic relationship with the
audience
almost like i'm mad that they like me
like yeah they're like why
why why am i why are they doing this are
they crazy i was like mad
and it's not like an imposter syndrome
it's just more of like i lose respect
for you if you like
too much kind of thing maybe yeah yeah
or there's also because comedy is sort
of like i've done this
every night for the past four months and
you're laughing at it yeah like i fuck
you know what i mean
yeah but that's when it's at its best
but you're like oh you guys fucking have
no
i've been doing this yeah how do you not
see through this right right it's
weird but now i'm just like because they
like it and it makes them happy
yeah and that's okay yeah like that's
that is okay yeah after this pandemic i
think it's okay for humans to want to be
happy
so if we learn anything here today it's
that if you like the lucas brothers
they're fine with it that's it if you
like us we're cool with it
we're not angry anymore we got it all
out of our system
you're allowed to know their jokes yes
and uh and still love them
you want to say plain slimes what do you
mean we're going to do
oh you like me you have shitty taste you
can do better
there are better comedians out there we
are going to stop charging you money
and then shaming you when you like us
right how about that
i'm over it no i think that's that's i
think a lot of things we
we pathologize or over pathologizes
comedians are actually what serves us
the most
like when a lot of communities are like
i have anxiety i'm like i'd hope so
like if you don't have anxiety you're
not awake right you should be like well
this is gonna happen this is gonna
happen
like of course you should yeah you know
like i'm socially awkward like
i don't say that but um yeah you should
because as a comedian we do well with
comedians but then we go out with
regular people and we're like hey
open yeah just sort of like oh let me
show you my tits and they're like uh i'm
calling hr
so it's like we are awkward we shouldn't
be right you know so i think there's
like there's certain parts of ourselves
that we need to stop like
flagellating because it's our job to
self-criticize what is our job to be
like oh yeah that is a fucking
superpower actually that i thought was a
weakness or a flaw that
has made me good at this absolutely i
may not be able to like go to baby
showers
without embarrassing myself who wants to
go yeah i might be single forever
but like i can write a fucking joke
exactly right and that's the goal
yeah that's it to perfect it okay and i
do
um judas in the black messiah if you
have
i will be watching it again because it
is the kind of thing you have to watch
i think once because you just to get
through the emotion of it
and then i re-watched like the first
part and i was just watching jessie's
performance
and then i was just watching like and
then you're just and then one to just
watch the filmmaking
and the choices that the director made
you know so it's just it's
so much once you once you get through
that like emotionally raw
part and you you confront that history
you watch it that first time i think
when you go back and watch it you
appreciate it on a filmmaking level
because that's the thing is that
the filmmaking was so um uh
uh um conducive to the
story being told that i wasn't looking
at that i mean the testament of good
filmmaking is not thinking about it
right you're just lost in it but then to
to purge the feelings and then go
through and be like this cut jesus this
scene is like seven minutes long yeah
right i didn't notice that before i
thought you know because most scenes
that you're compelled by are cut a ton
and manipulated and there's music or
whatever and it's like this is
you know so um if students of film
this is for you right and all white
people
you are obligated to watch this movie um
i love you guys is there anything else
you want to say
on drugs uh uh i love this special
i remember i the art is so good that i
mean i remember watching the special be
like
fuck they're gonna like be filmmakers
because i was like there's like richard
nixon
was like wasn't he bored i was like
richard nixon from the lebowski uh
picture we're big fans of big lebowski
i was like this is so fucking innovative
and specials are not supposed to be
innovative
and now you're going to go fucking be
like gerard and go like have a
production company and go make movies
and like
judd apatow or some shit and like you're
fucking up the bell curve for the rest
of us
and like now i have to like think about
my set i don't know like this
set design because you're making it like
art i'm sure some people were very upset
by that but
it's like really you know some people
are like man that's kind of weird
what people who are these people the old
school guys
you know they're like just get to the
jokes comics
i don't know comics are upset by anyone
that's successful
you know what i'm saying like you're
just successful it's not what had
nothing to do with it was the fact that
you just had a special that you deserve
to have that's right
you know and they're still middling in
tampa
because they're doing fat chicks jokes
and they don't understand why they can't
make it right
what do you mean i have a joke about how
asians can't drive
like why don't i have a special you know
you're right you're right
there's an old school mentality where
they can't recognize that sometimes
their the stealthness of their act isn't
allowing for them to sort of
you know breakthrough breakthrough yeah
and it was also like i got a lot of shit
i mean
we say that because we we're also the
people that if there's five thousand
people laughing and one people's not we
go
everyone you know what i mean you
motherfucker what would you like to do
which is why we're good which is why
you're good
you know you have to like if one person
the focus group says i don't get this
and the rest say they you got you also
have to honor that reaction because
one out of ten absolutely that's going
to be 10 out of 100 and 100 of a
thousand or whatever i hope that math
was right
very soon a future line producers uh
sorry
yeah to drag you into that migraine but
um but yeah i think that being overly
critical you have to i mean
watching that movie i was like this was
a very overly critical group of people
that would not stop until
every frame was fucking and that's why
right there's this war on perfectionism
that i don't understand
why are you such perfectionists you're
making movies in art and stand up
because you respect your audience be
worse you're trying to secure
a man's legacy so that's the extra level
of stakes you know you don't want to you
don't want to fuck up chairman
you're not a little bit fine let's just
cast steve harvey
daniel's busy you can handle it
i feel like
he's a good actor he's a very good actor
but i remember when the richard pryor
movie was casting
he was supposed to he was he was cast as
me right and then
you know who it was the next iteration
was marlon wayne's no
nick cannon yeah and apparently he was
amazing
i could see that yeah i want to say was
in the mix as well but i think he was
like ah this is too
yeah much or something right um i don't
i don't know i i
would have to ask him but um right but
yeah but nick cannon was apparently
amazing
playing richard pryor i can see that
being very true yeah really yeah
yeah are you he can have anybody guess
once you've been married to mariah carey
from in terms of stress i mean could you
imagine being married to a pop singer
no i'm just a pop singer the one
yeah the great the greatest one yeah and
then
being a funny person than having to host
serious shows the amount of rage
need to be seen differently yeah i kind
of i've spent a lot of time sort of like
getting into that like the idea of being
like playing richard like how could you
ever
yeah you know like that must be so hair
i mean there's a reason it hasn't been
done
i would yeah assume i don't think i
don't know
someone's working on the film i think uh
kenya barrett team bears kenya and yeah
i believe daniels was doing it for a
minute
can you embarrass yeah now it's like
it's it's kind of one of those where
you're like
you know i think they should hire uh the
two people
i would say is uh what's the guy's name
he was a youtuber but now he's like
oh marvin greg martin yeah oh marvin who
marvin greg myron greg or uh darryl yeah
yeah daryl
those two guys i think we should be and
then the thing that i thought about was
like
jamie foxx when he did rey we were all
like jamie and then you were like you
killed it
blew it out of there you're like holy
stand-ups can do anything
i agree there's a delusional amount of
confidence in such a deep need to be
liked and respected
they'll figure it out yeah yeah they
will fucking figure it out because their
ultimate fear is being embarrassed
right so and nothing you know nothing
stops that yeah
and then after they it's like dad do you
love me now
still no okay no matter how many awards
you win dad didn't call
okay i still hate myself it's just like
it's
endless we will never ever like
think we're great right right which
keeps us trying to get better yeah right
yeah thanks dad
thank you can you send your dad a flat
of an edible arrangement
thank you were you wrong he was an
amazing father
by abandoning right that was the spark
we needed that was you know the key to
our act
and the key to our creative process
there was a um we needed that dad to
leave
someone had a joke about this i don't
remember who it was about like when um
female comics are molested
that's like athletes and sports taking
steroids like it's cheating because
you're just funnier if you're the more
trauma you've had so
you were molested she's funny because
she was molested it's not fair like
it's a joke
um i love you uh and i'll see you soon
next time you're in town i hope
yes we're going to come stay here yeah
we should do it we should put on the
show too dad
i was putting shows on um i know why why
didn't you invite us because you were
in new york right i will fly out here to
to be on the show but it will but we'll
shoot it we'll shoot
because yeah i want to for you there's
certain stuff that's like this isn't for
netflix this isn't for special but like
this i want to say it and
sure you know chapter in the moment yeah
totally yeah just like put it up
totally down yeah you know or even like
a story that like this wouldn't go into
special but i want to kind of
see the reaction to it you know whatever
right yeah i feel like a lot of like
what we're doing now is like uh what do
you call we said it this morning though
you said you just want to you just want
to experimental
just do stuff experimental yeah i
already like i already achieved
something in film it's like i don't have
that burden anymore so it's just like i
want to just there's a freedom to like
now like
now i need what's the thing that's gonna
be as exciting as
trying to make this movie for 10 years
exactly let me discover something else
about myself i can do that let's see if
i can do this
right let's see if i can go on stage and
not make a joke
let me hang in that silence yeah i'll be
hanging in a little bit i'm like
chapelle i remember uh i saw him at
montreal one year
and he was just i mean between every
joke was like
a minute and a half i mean he does not
rush
it was just like and he was like sitting
there smoking and it was like we were
you could hear pin drop yeah you hang on
every moment there was a rapper there
wasn't a cell phone and then it was like
and the kind of tension the laugh was
just like
like old emo like it was like releasing
old pain
it was just wild right are you doing
montreal this year
is it montreal happiness is in l.a you
have something i have a
general rule where i try to not bomb for
my own agents
like the festival thing i i've done them
before but i just like
you know i always i feel like i don't
know what i'm doing
you know what i'm saying because i'm
like are we burning this material we're
using it like doing the galas
like and i did the gala once i hosted it
once and it i think it went okay
but i i was like oh this is material i
can't use now on
i'm doing my a shit because i want to
impress everyone at the festival and you
know but
now i'm burning a bunch of stuff and
then one time i did um
a gala that was hosted by steve martin
and it was at like five and i didn't
know that
that show was all people that have
like year-round tickets to the theater
so it's not really like comedy fan
it's just people that go to the opera
and stuff and it just happens to be
comedy and i
ate shit in a way
that was so shocking it was shocking
like it was
it was so it was i gave a speech uh
for eight minutes and i and like steve
martin is standing right there and i'm
just like this is
my literal nightmare right and it's it
was older people too
and i'm like so i'm squirting i was at a
time when i was just it was just not a
match and then orni adams went on i was
like they're kind of tough
i was like tough crowd you're never just
killed first joke out it was like uh
i called customer service and any guy
answers boom and i was like
fuck dude i have no excuse uh so but
yeah i i love going just because i get
to see comedians
right that's something they're like
hanging out but there's something but i
think with the new faces and all that
stuff they had to have sort of a thing
about they weren't paying the new fee
they weren't
because the trip is you know it's
fucking two thousand dollars
you know so it was like there was a
little bit of like working out how to
pay the younger comics
and the more established comics taking
less money i think aria shapiro was kind
of digging into that stuff so
um uh i haven't heard much but yeah i
don't i don't
i don't think i am right right i mean i
would like to go to canada
yeah forever yeah i love montreal yeah
yeah
yeah but um yeah but it's really i i
feel like the reason i'm doing a podcast
is like i get to see comedians
and there's this thing where comedians
won't hang out anymore unless it's being
monetized
so i was like i guess i have to start a
podcast to hang out with us
you know we are yeah it's like what i
get to do you know
um but yeah it's so funny to think of
all the things that are gone now
i know yeah the tbs festival vegas
comics new york with an ex i knew
something was off about that business
model
the food was good i was like the food
can't be too good people can't come for
the food
yeah and then they're paying attention
to the people
when people try to open comedy clubs
that haven't had them before it's just
like they're like oh this will work
it can't be too nice the food can't be
too good yep you know people can't be
too comfortable i see these things down
where everyone's like here and i'm like
no no you have to be in a hard seat
where you're you know right erect right
and paying attention the comedy story
started serving food which is
interesting
they haven't they never had food because
mitzi didn't want anyone to be
uh doing anything except watching the
comedy oh yeah yeah well you need food
you need food now because the hours are
probably longer and people are probably
staying there a little longer yeah i
totally like
the comics to eat she i think there was
like popcorn was the only thing that
they had
she also like didn't want people choking
on food or something and i was like yeah
that was back when jim carrey was there
like preaching about politics like i
think you're safe i think we're good
you can serve four course meals
twitter instagram yes only fans
yeah we have twitter lucas bros and then
instagram is the lucas price
no only fans
people make a lot of money there's a way
to do it
there's a way to do it that's not you
know i wanted to do a roast of comedians
telling like
dirty jokes yeah that you could never
tell on anything that's fun
that's funny and you can get away with
it yeah
it's like monetization they'd not get
naked but just to be like oh these are
those jokes we
would have been able to you know what i
mean and it's
just for us and we get paid for it yeah
that's brilliant you know
yeah oh and would you like record like
you in front of people or
are you recording i was like let's just
do in the backyard here where we all
kind of roast each other
so it doesn't feel like we're just like
it's you know friends and not just like
let's
be like a stereotype yeah it's like sort
of like i could never
like the kind of stuff because we were
out here doing open mics during the
pandemic
and uh when we weren't filming and it
was like five or six of us we were like
we would just be like
ripping like jokes that you could only
do in the belly room ten years ago at
two a.m
yeah it was a god that felt so good to
say hey that's so much but we could
never say that anywhere
so much i miss the open mics where you
can just say whatever right and you're
really just performing for the comics in
the background
you know you're trying to get them to
laugh you're just like scientology aids
age quilt like you're just like the shit
you're not allowed to say and then
putting it on only fans
so there's no standards and practices
and then we can raise the money and
donate it to something you know
anti-defamation league because we've
been doing so much today
um i love i end these very awkwardly i
love you
thank you don't write elephants goodbye
[Music]